[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
Capone or not to bone
oh
is that really the question good Lord
oh boy
Hell Boy it gives the Cheeto chop new
meaning doesn't it if Carrie Lake and
Donald Trump are schlubbing
that's the story I Hey listen I don't
get to make the rules on these things
okay I don't get to make the rules on
these things I I just look at the news
and I'm commentating on it
and it seems like that manga is out in
front trying to portray Carey Lake as
some sort of supermodel so that way when
it does truly get found out that these
two are you know
bumping bumping insurrectionist Douglas
then um
I don't know what you want me to do what
do you want me to do I don't I don't I
don't get to pick which stories are out
front
I don't get to pick what story We lead
in okay maybe I'm guilty here of um
finding this story hilarious hilarious
I'm not kidding you
um Rhonda Santos's team is trying to
make it seem like Carrie Lake and Donald
Trump are are doing the dirty they're
fooling around
right
they're they're trying really hard
no pun intended
there's a story out in people that uh
Carey lake has been spending a lot of
time at Mar-A-Lago hmm she's been living
there as a matter of fact
kinda
you know it's not surprising
um I actually was in a room a Twitter
space with Carrie Lake
and I told you about this I don't know
it was a couple months ago when Kerry
Lake was still trying to act like she's
gonna be governor of Arizona or some
dumb [__] right she's lost every [__]
lawsuit it's over you're not the
governor
I mean you've lost a thousand times the
election now of being the governor of
Arizona
if she's being sued there's a defamation
lawsuit by a head Republican official in
Arizona for the defamation of him just
outright lies she knows their lies and
she continues to [__] propagate them
all over the country but that's Carrie
Lake's team's defense it's like look hey
okay Carrie lake is trying to be vice
president okay
and she travels all around the country
speaking about these things including at
Mar-A-Lago well and apparently she's
been seen uh on a boat with a trump blow
up doll I'm not kidding you I'm gonna
show you the [__] picture of Carrie
Lake on a boat with a trump blow up doll
this is a real thing
uh what do you want me to do I'm just
trying to draw wedges between team
DeSantis and team Trump that's all I'm
trying to do folks if you haven't caught
on because I'm very transparent here on
the Tony Michaels podcast about what I'm
trying to do by politicizing every
single [__] issue that's right and
drawing wedges down in between Maga and
Geck you know what gak is
Rhonda Santos's cult
gak and Maca I'm I'm here to break them
apart make them fight it out a cage
match like Elon and old zucky get in
there and really [__] each other up
that's what I see throw some punches you
[__]
I'm just pointing out the fact
[Laughter]
so that's the story is that Kerry lake
is living in a villa but Carrie Lake was
in that Twitter space with me
she was there to be interviewed they
wanted me to come in and ask her
questions or something I can't even I
think I was on stage at one point with
her but they really were she was
monopolizing the entire microphone right
I mean that was the point of it was to
have Carrie Lake give her great insights
into American politics all wise 100
[__] all lies
full stop the whole time but one thing
she said that was very interesting to me
it was very interesting to me
because the question came up
is Carrie Lake going to be
his vice presidential running mate right
is she gonna be the vice president on
his presidential ticket when he gets the
nomination that was the question which I
mean maybe it's a legitimate question it
seems a little ridiculous
that our country would
[__] put Donald Trump the election
denier and the election denier Cara Lake
on a ticket of a major party only to
[__] lose majorly even before it gets
started
right seems ridiculous but
in this [__] crazy timeline it could
happen
nothing is off the the net job table as
it were but here's the thing Carrie Lake
said something that was very interesting
about this and to the to the question
rather she would be
uh his vice presidential running mate
she said this and and this actually
makes me think that Donald Trump is
going to try to run without
a vice presidential Running Man and the
reason why is because no one really is
Gonna Wanna Be
right by that point and the reason why
is because by the time we get to the
Republican National Convention next year
they're going to be looking for any way
for Donald Trump to not win with the
delegate votes that he has
I mean they're really going to be
desperate I mean it's good it could it
could turn out to be
um a violent chaos to be quite honest at
the Republican National Convention next
summer
When Donald Trump comes to the
convention with enough delegates to win
on the first ballot
and he's mired in in legal woes the guy
is not only indicted in New York on 34
felonies and 37 felonies in South
Florida on the Espionage Act but it
looks like today the reason why Grandpa
was freaking out yesterday isn't because
Carrie Lake's trying to
pole dance on him oh God oh God
um yeah uh Apparently one of his major
campaign staff who was part of the state
elector scheme went and testified in
front of Jack Smith's
grand jury
for the January 6 part of Jack Smith
invest Jack Smith Jack Smith's
investigation
so that seems to be more worrisome still
that Donald Trump is going to be charged
in the January 6 case sooner rather than
later
possibly before the Republican National
Convention that's why time is of the
essence here for him to secure the
nomination that's why you see like wheel
herd getting in and all these other
[__] getting in the race
and Donald Trump isn't going to
discourage this and the reason why is
because it smashes up the donor class it
divides up the donor class
of who's taking what money and support
which only hurts DeSantis
and Trump doesn't exactly need big
dollar donors in this in this race he
just needs enough money to get on the
ballots and not money to pretend that
he's the front runner and his cult will
do the rest of the work
okay that's that's what I mean Rhonda
santis and any of these other uh people
who are trying to run for the Republican
nomination this Republican primary what
they really are trying to do is convince
the Trump cult that he's no longer a
good cult leader make me cult leader
right right that's that's their cell
it's not working even if the media says
that it's working it's not folks listen
the [__] was charged and
arraigned on 37 felonies in South
Florida on the Espionage Act
because he was [__] harboring and
stole National Security information is
waving it around in front of people who
couldn't see it okay
so if ROM DeSantis isn't swapping him I
mean absolutely swamping him in the
primary polls Rhonda santis isn't moving
at all okay Rhonda santis is spending
[__] boatloads of money trying to
move this poll two percent
against a guy who is criminally
convicted on over 70 felonies
aren't excuse me not convicted indicted
sorry oh man
he's indicted on over 70 felonies at
this point by the time we get to next
summer the Republican National
Convention he's going to have probably
double maybe even triple the amount of
felonies [__] who knows
and Ronda Santos isn't swamping him in
the polls Rhonda santis is losing this
race badly
huge huge
and their best play Rhonda Santos's best
play here is to try to convince
the Maga cult that somehow Trump is
boning Kerry Lake
are you [__] [__] me
that's your best play
oh my God you gotta be [__] kidding
me
listen Ron listen dude just man throw a
real [__] punch man get out in front
of a microphone and start talking about
how the cult leader is a dumb
[__] and he's a crook a criminal
and it's not weaponization against him
he's just a stupid [__] wannabe
mobster
start punching him you dumb [__]
if if you think Ronnie meatball
that not laying hands on him over the
weaponization of government and all
these cases are gonna go your way you
are stupid that is his worst that is his
worst weakness here
take advantage of it dig into it start
pounding him you stupid bastard
stop talking about Covenant lockdowns no
one gives a [__] besides the handful of
[__] trolls on Twitter
but I'm gonna give you proof from a
trump Lackey a trump simp a cult member
Crazy a lunatic
you know her Laura Loomer oh my God this
[__] idiot whoosh I've been in
Mario's [__] Twitter spaces with her
too she's a nut bag I think actually it
might have been her in there with DC
Drano that I said your people's delusion
is gonna be Trump's ultimate demise
I mean it's it's gonna happen eventually
[Laughter]
maybe the demise is carry lake living at
Mar-A-Lago maybe maybe that is his
Federal sentence I mean wouldn't it be a
[__] horrible experience to have to
live with Gary Lake oh my God how
[__] horrible would that be Jesus
Christ I would say I would say um Satan
could punish Hitler with that punishment
nope you got to live with Carrie for the
rest of your [__] rest of your
miserable life
I'd say that would be enough enough
punishment for anybody wouldn't it oh
okay let's go to a different story
because I I can't I can't oh man this is
hilarious right everyone is
um really torn on how funny this Titan
thing is uh you know you know the beer
can that sunk at the bottom of the ocean
near the Titanic
oh boy so the right wing
the righties the righties this morning
are [__] big man they're super mad
that what is supposed to be a wish.com
Elon Musk
got convinced a bunch of Rich dumbasses
to hop into a beer can
and as their own coffin and sink it to
the bottom of the ocean
now here's the story you guys know this
we've covered it a little bit on on this
uh this tourism whatever the hell they
want to call it extreme tourism uh of
the ocean Gates Titanic right
now we we've
no one knew about this really until just
over the weekend because the Coast Guard
the Navy uh Canadians Navy the French
navy we're all out looking for this
submersible our submarine or vessel
whatever the [__] you want to call it I
call it a beer can with cinder blocks
did I do it because I mean what's the
[__] difference here
so they paid 250 000 to get into this
thing to go to the Bottom of the Sea and
die now apparently on Sunday the Navy
heard a sound and yet you gotta remember
they're using equipment out in the ocean
to try to detect any kind of [__] any
kind of evidence of where this thing is
at right and they're spending gazillions
of our tax dollars Canadian tax dollars
France tax dollars to do this for a
bunch of [__] Millionaires and
billionaires who hopped in this beer can
and paid 250 000 a piece [__] out of
here with this nonsense first off just
on his face it's ridiculous but
apparently the United States Navy this
is important the Navy
heard a sound detected a sound recorded
a sound that may have been an implosion
right on Sunday they alerted the Coast
Guard okay the Coast Guard the Navy
found the sound righties okay are you
listening you [__] weirdos the Navy
heard the sound they recorded it they
don't know if it's an implosion or not
it just it seems like that could be it
and they alerted the Coast Guard who was
in command are you following do you know
out do you know how you know how words
were command of the search and rescue
the Navy was not in the command of the
search and rescue they were there to
assist their assistance was hey um it
seems like there was an implosion and it
might be that vessel
so the command at the Coast Guard who
was in charge of the search and rescue
said well that sounds like it could be
it
um but we don't want to stop searching
in case it's not because if there are
people alive then it's crucial and
critical that we keep searching that
that that's how um search and rescue
works
okay
now here's the thing
they found debris at the bottom of the
ocean yesterday and the reason why is
because they finally got of a piece of
equipment on scene that could actually
get down to that [__] to pull it
out or yank it out you know like you're
yanking a [__] car out of the ditch
with a four-wheel drive truck in the
middle of winter you ever done that you
ever had toe strap you had to wrap that
[__] around the bumper and yank
real hard to get the car out of the
ditch because it's slid in there because
the ice and snow not exactly the same
thing just like it's not exactly the
same thing when you hand build some
jerry-rigged [__] beer can with
cinder blocks tied to it as a real
submersible that can go two and a half
miles down to the bottom of the ocean to
see the Titanic again not really
comparable but you get the gist
oh but the right Wingers this morning
are sick
they're big [__] mad that this this
wish.com Elon Musk who built this vessel
convinced a bunch of Rich ass dummies to
get into this [__] crumpled up beer
can and go to the bottom of the ocean
and die in it they're pissed off about
that so much so that they're blaming Joe
Biden
are you [__] me here's their here's
their Theory
I can't even this is this is [__]
worse
than the Trump schlubbing Carrie Lake
story okay this is the [__] I don't
know what to tell you this is
the time we live in
this is the time we live in when really
we should be talking about you know like
uh making sure children have school
lunch uh making sure that your schooling
starts at three instead of five you know
for a lot of different reasons to start
early childhood education relief parents
of I I don't know daycare costs that
sort of thing make sure you don't go
broke because of a medical bill hey that
would be a hell of a thing to talk about
that would be a hell of a thing for our
Congress and our politicians and our
government to be working on you know
what's you know it's a real success is
the Secretary of Transportation and the
governor of Pennsylvania Josh Shapiro
they got together and they're fixing the
[__] I-95 bridge in 13 [__] days
it's opening today almost I think right
now just about right now there's
probably traffic going across that son
of a [__] after it collapse these are
the things that we need to be taking
care of I don't know like climate change
causing fires and making New York an
orange ridden smog Fest again there's a
lot of things we could be talking about
and doing but when you live in the land
of stupid
when you live in the land of stupid this
is the things that you have to mock them
for
and I know what it feels like oh well we
do this constantly and we do this to
ourselves no we hack we have to smoke
these morons out we have to show them
for who they are
otherwise the rest of the country is not
going to pay attention to them folks
they're not they're not going to pay
attention to the stupidity that is
running parts of our [__] country
we need to show the world that
Republicans are the party of dumb stupid
and cult and cultness okay that's what
we have to do and we have to yell and
scream until they finally wake up and go
oh yeah we shouldn't be voting
Republican if we want serious policy
or even a serious policy debate we
shouldn't even be [__] considering
these [__] wackos
that's what we have to do
but righties this morning on the
internet are claiming that Joe Biden on
Sunday after the Navy notified the
command
you can't make this [__] up notified the
command of the search and rescue at the
coast guard that they heard an implosion
giving them the the approximate location
of the implosion at that
so that they could continue their search
the command at the Coast Guard said no
our protocol is to keep searching this
is not definitive evidence until the
actual proper equipment received got on
the scene yesterday and was able to see
and confirm that parts of the the beer
can were wreckage at the bottom of the
ocean confirming that yes that implosion
was real and now our search is off
they're [__] dead
it you can't make this [__] up but they
think Joe Biden Joe Biden [__]
dementia ridden Joe Biden is sofa he's
so far out in front of these idiots he's
playing 6D chess
that he decided that what he would do is
use the Titan story to cover up the
hunter Biden so what the [__] are you
talking about cover up the hunter
binding Story the entire world heard the
in Hunter Biden story
that he took a plea deal you
[__] were yelling and screaming
about it the media was yelling and
screaming about [__] the media is even
playing into the stupid [__]
narrative this morning that the Navy was
trying to hide that they found an
implosion which is stupid they're like
oh well does it seem like the Navy hid
that this implosion get the [__] out of
here man
the media is so shitty at this they play
right into the right Winger's hands
every [__] time every time no what
actually happened was on Sunday the Navy
detected a [__] sound if it seemed
like to them that it was an implosion of
an of a craft of this type in that area
and they confirmed it yesterday when the
equipment got on scene to confirm it
it is what it appears to be you [__]
idiots
but no the right wing takes and runs
with it and they're like ah how dare you
Brandon
oh how dare you Brandon
I'm dead serious at blaming and
unbinding they're saying they used it to
cover up Hunter Biden's plea deal which
I don't know what the hell they're
talking about
the media was racking that [__] up from
front to back the other day I talked
about it
[__] I think that was wasn't that my
lead story hang on a second let me check
here let me check here
where is it where is it where is it
oh yes yes it was uh it was Tuesday
Tuesday
June 20th here was the title of the show
the title of the show is Trump can plead
guilty just like Hunter Biden
even me who's a shield for Biden oh I'm
the Derp state
talked about that story in my first 30
minutes it was in the title and on the
thumbnail
what the [__] are you talking about
the the Titan story was designed to
cover up the hunter binding story
frankly that was my lead in on Tuesday
and on Tuesday if you remember we stayed
over 20 minutes
after the show was over to talk about
this Titanic thing
not before I did the lead-in with Hunter
Biden you [__] buffoons
you just you can't fix stupid though
that's the problem here with moglodytes
you can't fix stupid the only thing you
can do is mock it and let it kind of you
know position yourself throw the rakes
out so they step on them speaking of
stepping on rakes a great story
yesterday
was the biggest rake since they censured
Adam Schiff which was the day before
damn
they passed a resolution on the house
floor
to send articles impeachment to the
Judiciary Committee
because Joe Biden he he's the president
so we won't impeach him for being the
president oh okay go ahead listen you're
mad because a United States Attorney Who
was appointed by Donald Trump to put
Hunter Biden and Joe Biden in jail
in Delaware he's appointed in Delaware
to investigate Hunter and Joe Biden and
they found [__] nothing they found in
discrepancies on his taxes Hunter
Biden's taxes and and they found out
that the dude's an addict and he
possessed a firearm why he's an addict
which is a [__] ridiculous Federal
charge anyways and every 2A bro out
there should be [__] mad that that's
even a possibility that's an
infringement upon someone's uh right to
bear arms isn't it if you're a [__]
addict should if you if you're an actor
I mean Jesus Christ will give anyone a
gun in Texas anyone a gun in Florida
without a background check without a
question [__] they can buy it on a
goddamn credit card the [__] stupid
ass that bought the [__] weapons that
went and killed dozens of children at
Uvalde he bought his [__] on the credit
card and didn't kill himself didn't even
have to pay for the gun
and you're telling me that charging
Hunter Biden or anyone in this country
for possession of a firearm because
they're an addict is an infringement on
their Second Amendment right get the
[__] out of here if you're not arguing
for that and you're a two-way bro you
are not serious about the Second
Amendment everything you say is a bunch
of [__] as far as I'm concerned all
of it every [__] bit of it
get the [__] out of here but we covered
it we covered it we talked about Hunter
I talked about Hunter with Texas Paul
for like an hour
what are you talking about the the
Titanic thing was a distraction the [__]
out of here
if these right Wingers they can't handle
it they have they have to find anything
they can because the conversation isn't
about Joe Biden it isn't about Hunter
Biden anymore they're gonna have a
really tough time it's gonna be a really
heavy lift folks because this morning
they're like oh there's an IRS
whistleblower there's another person we
paid to lie get the [__] out of here IRS
whistleblower for what that Hunter Biden
didn't do his taxes just right he paid
money that he owed to the IRS and then
they charged him in the federal court
with with not doing his taxes and paying
them when he wanted to okay what are you
what are you talking about a
whistleblower well they were trying to
cover it up yeah but he is taking a plea
deal
for federal [__] charges you stupid
[__] which most people who pay back
their taxes to the IRS when they get
caught not paying the appropriate amount
of taxes never [__] received Roger
Stone
Roger Stone and his wife paying like two
million dollars were the back taxes for
like the 10 years prior that he didn't
pay didn't receive one Federal charge
not one get the [__] out of here you
people are [__] brain dead delusional
and I'm telling you I'm telling you it's
going to be Trump's ultimate demise so
let them keep going hand them a shovel
let's get some bigger shovels someone
order a truckload of shovels and rakes
please we need them on iO Maga
it's gonna be great it's gonna be a
great summer oh my God and I can't wait
to show you I can't wait to show you the
photo of Kerry Lake
oh my God and the Trump blow up doll on
a boat she's in a [__] bikini and
she's
I don't know what she's doing to this
Trump blow up doll you're gonna have to
decide then I'm gonna show it to you
don't go anywhere even though you know
I'm gonna show this don't go anywhere
don't that don't touch that dial as they
saw on the radio we'll be right back
right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
trying to remember all the things you've
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with these
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
foreign
[Music]
I'm really blowing it out of proportion
really
I'm really trying to make a great story
out of this [__] weird right-wing
battle that they're having between
Rhonda Santos and Donald Trump uh about
Carrie lake living at Mar-A-Lago and
spending more time there than Melania
Trump but what am I supposed to do what
do you think I'm not gonna [__] drive
that wedge down in between them oh [__]
hell yeah I am you should be too
listen when you come here and listen to
this show it is very important
that you have fun number one we gotta
have fun if we do not have fun mocking
these people we're not doing it
correctly right because we need that
cathartic release
we have to have it this [__] world is
crazy man this is a crazy time to be
alive these people are [__] nut jobs
they're nuttier than squirrel turds okay
and we have to have some some relief
from it so we have to mark So You Gotta
Have Fun number one that's the most
important part of the show that's why I
structure it the way I do that's why
it's got the the sound of a right-wing
talk radio show I've got that a lot a
lot of people like Tony I didn't really
think until after five or ten minutes
listening to what you were saying I
thought you were right winger I mean
you're wearing a red [__] hat for
crying out loud which by the way I want
to make Red Hats wearable again that's
why I wear the red hat I don't I like
the color red
I like the color red they've ruined it
but I like the color red so we gotta
make Red Hats wearable again but here's
the thing
is a lot of people say Tony I had no
idea that you were a lefty you don't
look like a lefty you don't sound like a
lefty well that may be true but come and
listen the show is structured in a
certain way is to keep you entertained
to listen from the front to the back
right that's the whole purpose what what
how good of a show host would I be if my
show was not designed for you to listen
to the entire thing right think about
this for a second
think about this most political shows
especially on the left
they're like well we want to get the
facts to the people we want to make sure
that they have all the data and they
have the entire story and but they
they're bored to death so they turn the
channel what the [__] no why why do you
want people to turn the channel why do
you want them to be bored why why just
because you have to you have to back up
all your commentary with certain sets of
data let me show you a graph of what I'm
saying that is true it's really stupid
to talk down to people right it's really
[__] dumb but left does this a lot
and I'm bashing the left here you know
who it is I don't have to [__] point
or do I need to point fingers because I
could if you want me to
ah the left is really shitty at this and
the reason why there is no lit actual
liberal media
is because the mainstream media tries to
appear to be non-biased to the truth so
they capitulate to the right well [__]
that we don't do that [__] here we
don't capitulate to them I don't give
their [__] I don't give their
narrative not not one inch not one inch
we mock the [__] out of their narrative
the entire time that's the whole purpose
this show is set up so it's entertaining
so you can watch not just for one hour
not just for two hours but maybe one of
these days for three full hours every
[__] weekday every single one of them
and you and you want to watch the entire
time
because there's no telling what I might
say or what stories or what [__] I might
put on the screen
that's the point
like I okay so I teased Carrie Lake
possibly maybe having
sexual advances to a trump blow up doll
earlier on I'm gonna wait to show you
here for I don't know another 15-20
minutes so you stick around to see what
the hell I'm talking about when I'm
talking about Carrie Lake might be doing
certain things of the Trump blow up doll
right that's the whole point that's the
whole point right yes yes am I leading
you along sure but I'm trying to
entertain you I'm trying to make
Politics the best I can cathartic and
entertaining from the left the right
does this all the time why do you think
we're at the intersection of
WrestleMania in real life folks why do
you think Donald Trump even exists folks
because they make it a total reality
show dumpster fire that you can't look
away from okay they've known this for a
long time A Long Time Rush Limbaugh was
perfecting this back in the early 90s
which led to Fox News which led to the
rise of right-wing talk radio
and it completely [__] mind [__]
this country into believing that Donald
Trump is oh he's a good political leader
he'll make a good president
they mind [__] a certain portion of
this country and they keep doing it I
mean we see it this week with the
censorship of Adam Schiff Kevin McCarthy
he was defeated he didn't want to do
that he knows he knows he's going to go
down in history now as the [__] most
unserious speaker ever in the history of
ever
and one of the reasons why is because
he's gonna be [__] bookended by Nancy
Pelosi one of the most effective
speakers of the house in our modern time
and Hakeem Jeffries
who is probably going to be the longest
serving Speaker of the House of our
[__] modern times okay and that's
going to be up to you it's going to be
up to you the pro-democracy coalition to
get out there and engage in your
democracy to make sure that Democrats at
all costs take the house back from these
[__] unserious schlubs these fascist
these megalodites who have no policy
whatsoever to even be arguing the only
thing they want to do is score points on
social media and Fox News that's it
that's their entire job as a republican
of the House of Representatives
so yeah am I gonna [__] mock them you
goddamn right I am am I going to try to
make it entertaining so you can see how
to mock them you goddamn right I am do
you know how important it is for you as
the pro-democracy coalition to go out
into the world and to mock these
[__] stupidity every single day
anytime you can in front of people who
would be ashamed if they supported these
fools yes it is this is how we turn it
around this is how we get the fascists
to go hide back underneath their rocks
by propagating that they're fools
and that anyone who supports them at any
level of government it doesn't matter
you're a fool too and you're not serious
about your [__] country your
patriotism or your way of life you're
willing to throw it all away for a bunch
of idiots
so yeah am I serious about this show you
goddamn right I am am I serious about
making sure that we are the number one
[__] show in politics you goddamn
right I am
does it take a lot of profanity poetry
to do it maybe does it not maybe not but
I kind of like it you kind of like the
salt and pepper of a few [__] here and
there
makes it sound modern a lot more modern
than right wing talk radio
but yes I'll admit oh Tony don't be so
transparent don't tell us what you're
doing I will what I'm doing is is is a
structure of political content and
commentary that people want to listen to
that people are interested in listening
to that they can't look away from
that is the most important thing in
Media
and they don't understand it and by they
I mean most the people on the left have
no clue they have no clue they haven't
learned anything over the last 40 years
about media and why the rise of fascism
happened in our country it isn't because
fascism is a great idea
it isn't because fascism
we don't know the risk of fascism in our
world and in our country get the [__]
out of here we know this stuff
it's because they use the media to give
cathartic release of people who thought
they were [__] worked against
and they played played right into the
hands of white Christian nationalists
for 40 years almost 50. 40 for sure with
the media
and they've done it and the way that
they've done it is not to get you to
listen because of what they're saying
they've got you to listen because how
they are saying it right am I right I
know I'm right I know I'm right I know
I'm correct you know why because we have
a small channel here let me let me give
you an example let me show you some
proof here
let me see what it is currently right
now as I speak we got 16 096 subscribers
on our YouTube channel which by the way
you should go ahead and just [__]
click that subscribe button we need to
be out of a million six to be quite
honest with you and I'm gonna explain
why here in a second
we have just 16 000 subscribers on our
YouTube channel that is I don't know if
you know this that sounds like a lot to
some people but that is a very small
very small YouTube channel we are very
small in comparison
to a lot of YouTube channels
let me give you another number yesterday
we had 2500 people at one point watching
live across platforms on our show
there is okay so you take that number
2500 all right you're like oh what man
that's way more that's way more than
even 10 of your subscriber base is
watching live
now let's multiply that just by 10.
let's say some people think we should
have a hundred and sixty thousand
subscribers on our YouTube channel still
not a big Channel but not a small
Channel either we're getting into the
medium-sized channels right with 160 000
subscribers now think about think about
if we had as many live viewers which I
know we will at that point
I know we will we'll have that many live
viewers loyal live viewers rather you
love me or you [__] love to hate me
you'll come here and you'll watch every
[__] day from the minute that
elevator music starts till the end when
the head ass is speaking and you know
what I'm talking about every [__] one
of you know what I'm talking about
because you watch until the very end
it's designed that way
I do it that way that's the whole point
and I'm telling you it's gonna happen
I need your help but it's gonna happen
it's gonna happen
and imagine the numbers imagine 10 times
in that number 25 000 people watching
then imagine if we double that that's 50
000 people watching at one time
I believe I believe this show right here
could go three hours a day and we could
get millions of viewers every single day
half of them love me half of them love
to hate me
I'm not kidding you
I believe that is that is exactly what
we can do
and I and I need your help you are the
best audience in the world and the
reason why is because you guys do stay
and I do see the numbers on the back end
our watch time our our views our amount
of views over the last few months have
been almost exactly the same and Gabe
Sanchez here he can attest to this our
views on our YouTube channel have pretty
much remained almost exactly the same
over the last few months right I mean
they've gone up a little bit yeah yeah
pretty much statistically about the same
yeah our watch time is like 35 percent
higher which means which means the same
amount of people are watching but
they're watching more of the show means
that we are doing something correct
that's the whole point I I that would
that would seem to be the case I don't
know I'm you know I'm not doing any
meganomics here but that looks right
right right and you know it's incredible
that we only have 16 000 subscribers on
our main Channel on YouTube and
yesterday I mean today today we're at
about 18 1900 across platforms which is
usually typical we well for a while
there we were going like a thousand to
1200 and then we were about 14 to 1600
now here lately we've had anywhere
between 18 and 2000. yesterday we had
over 2500 people watching what 2500
people watching
that's not that seems like a big number
to some it might not seem like a big
number to others but I'll give you an
example and a lot of people out there
um know some channels that have many
more subscribers than we do and they
don't pull
that many of you are live viewers and
there's some channels that had way more
I mean I'm talking about half a million
600 000 yeah before they were pulling
that many live viewers and the reason
why is because again how we do this show
how it's set up how it's organized I
mean I tease the audience in the
beginning uh today right and I even let
them in on the in on this gag here that
I'm going to show them a picture of
Carrie Lake maybe you're maybe not doing
something uh nefarious to a Donald Trump
blow up doll I it's a real photo too and
I don't get this Twisted some are saying
some are saying Gabe Sanchez that this
might be where did you find this is
something else dude
all I'm gonna say is uh
I know some people who know some people
who are the people that take photos of
this this grotesque couple yeah when
they're out and about but hey somebody
hey people are going to tell you it's
Photoshop and I'm gonna tell you no it's
the real deal man no way no way is that
you couldn't zoom in and figure out if
that was Photoshop no not at all not no
no no no no no no
you definitely don't know how to use
Photoshop either yeah you know it's it's
definitely not like somebody would have
spent I don't know seven minutes trying
to think of what image to composite
together if any if anyone's wondering
why the show link was late today
it's because of this image possibly uh
may or may not have been being
constructed somewhere in a derp State
Photoshop uh bunker somewhere yeah I
don't know I got I got the request
straight from Soros find me that photo
right and I found that photo we we got
it we got it here
um so
what is with this dude did you read the
story about this carry Lake thing that
people did didn't need to because you
know why I already knew yeah uh
that she'd been spending I mean like
after her loss multiple losses in her
her race for governor and yeah she lost
she's lost like 18 times or some [__] or
is I thought it was 87. it could be well
there's an eight in there somewhere
right yeah yeah Gematria right right uh
but what I what I remember is that after
her election after she lost she went
down to Mar-A-Lago and was like I'm
gonna be the governor I'm gonna fight
this thing cause all of these people
cheated
and she's pretty much like had residency
since it happened apparently according
to people she [__] lives there in a
villa
it's what they're saying man she spends
more time with Donald Trump than Melania
I I guess what onlookers are saying is
the only time that they see Donald Trump
and Melania really together is some sort
of event where they both would attend
but on a normal basis they have
breakfast in the Mar-A-Lago restaurant
there on Saturday mornings that's I love
how they have breakfast at the
restaurant
like they don't have like a dining hall
that they can eat together it's always
out in public because that's that also
goes to to tell you more about what
Donald Trump and Kerry Lake but Donald
Trump especially has to do right he has
to be seen in public despite the fact
that he looks like [__] right and he
struggles to like get a straw
that was one thing that was one thing
about the interview with Brett Baer that
we kind of had to Breeze over because it
was so [__] crazy is that his hair
looked like [__] it didn't even look
like Trump's hair yeah I don't know
who's doing his wigs here lately but God
damn yeah I mean who knows maybe maybe
Carrie lake is trying to get him to try
new hairstyle maybe maybe
the filter the filter Queen is trying to
fix up baby images
babe I need you to do this with your
hair it's gonna look great babe it's
gonna look great I know he's like
okay whatever you say what did you say
Carrie spray tan later you know
um it's just it
it again it just goes back to it makes
me laugh that he has to have breakfast
or lunch or dinner right he lives
does this exist wait wait wait uh 70 and
Holly said on YouTube says Carrie has
ketchup on for perfume is there is there
is there a ketchup
does it smell like ketchup well here we
go the scent of tomato here here we go
here we go uh Demeter fragrance Library
handcraft in the USA tomato
we love this scent so much it's really a
verb picking tomatoes the scent the
tomato leaves on your hands it reminds
our co-founder Christopher Christopher
Gable of his grandfather's farm when he
was a kid okay so this is more like so
it's not exactly it's not exactly
ketchup it's tomato plants do you know
what have you ever smelled them like I
mean you can almost throw on a bunch of
tomato plants at what it smells like
uh no okay well it has a distinct smell
in the garden when you're when you're
picking like when you're inside you know
a bunch of yeah but there are there are
Heinz in March of 2022. they launched
Aussie barbecue scented candles
so there's so there's ketchup scented
candles and supposedly
people asking on Reddit uh weird
question one of my customers recently
asked me to make a custom ketchup
scented soap Donald Trump maybe that
could be it could be Carrie Lake trying
to bathe in there you know as you
attract his pheromones you know what I
mean this person yeah I know this person
says I've done some searching and I'm
not seeing anything that smells like
ketchup does anyone have any
recommendations one person goes the
closest thing I've seen on ketchup would
be Steward Tomatoes fragrance oil by
saveonsense.com and then people are like
well I think if you mix tomato honey and
citrus and they basically just break
this thing down and somebody just goes
ew
okay okay so
um not to give away the game here maybe
you should put that on your list of uh
of content is a um a Carrie Carrie Lake
sponsored Heinz
um scent
please don't produce that piece of
content so we can play it on the show oh
please you know what ketchup it's a
great segue
into your piece of content you gotta
what was that for us right I do I do
actually I was reminded yeah because
people kept asking about this hat yeah
and you can actually get the Hat uh I
opened up a second store because the
first one wasn't doing it for me
um but I need to change do I need to
change the link on the yeah I'm gonna
update it later today and then okay
it'll it'll automatically update but yes
I've oh no so so the link that I have on
the web let me make sure yeah yeah it
will it will be that link I just have to
update on my end oh okay but it's I just
want to make sure that that um that
whatever that link is it goes directly
yeah yeah so people have been asking
like oh can I get a son of an immigrant
hat you know and uh I wasn't gonna make
one or rather let me explain this
um
I made one that was child of an
immigrant right that way it's not
daughter it's not Sun you know you could
it because also daughter is like way too
long on the top and whole thing so
anyway you can go to actually you can go
to my YouTube and you can buy them from
straight there right now
I have it linked in
you know I I think do we have your
YouTube on the
other website we should put your YouTube
on the website there too yeah I need to
yeah do that yeah do that yeah yeah but
anyway yes you asked about content and
yes it I think there is a connection
here with a certain somebody uh
uh Donald Trump this is a what was that
right so this is a what was that and the
what was that is all around this claim
it starts with this claim that Ron
DeSantis made which was
um
if I had to he's like if I had to have
dinner with anyone blah blah blah uh I
think I could go back with Jesus time
and hang out with his disciples okay
very crazy claim to make especially
considering his past and then
there's stuff about Donald Trump in
there and the Republican Party there's a
whole section on Margaret Taylor green
and Lauren bobert and I had to cut it
because I was gonna I'm gonna use it in
my next segment which is on Lauren
bobert saying that God told her to draft
articles of impeachment against Joe
Biden I had a whole section on Margaret
Taylor green and Lauren bobert and I was
like oh no no no no I gotta I gotta move
that over to this next episode because
it's way more relevant on these two
[__] bitching Queens
okay so
um let's go to the what was that before
we do that though I I uh since it has to
do with one of these people I wanna I
wanna show you this uh tweet from Rachel
Dr Rachel bitcover I'm really trying to
get her on this week but
um I think she's on vacation so I'm
hoping maybe next week we'll get doc
back on
um to talk about
um not only the arraignment of Donald
Trump but all the shenanigans in the
house because I think it's mockable and
Doc always does a fantastic job but here
she sends a tweet out about this story
because this is a this is a people story
she has the Apple news link here on this
tweet but it gets you right to the
people story yeah she says the fake
president and the fake Governor are
spending lots of time together without
the wife
um
and really honestly Gabe Sanchez before
we go to the what was that I want to
show you proof of this that I think this
there might be something to this and the
reason why is you know Laura Loomer is
oh yeah oh yeah the most boycotted band
canceled woman in America right she's
pretty crazy
um the thing is is that she she is
um
she's really kind of digging into the
whole story here and I believe that it's
um
I believe well let me just show you I I
tweeted this morning I said it seems
like Maga is trying to get out in front
of the story that
Carrie lake is boning Grandpa
and the reason why is because Laura
Loomer
who is a um
who who is a
um a Maga simp she's a trump Sim she
would love to be on his team she's not
officially it's an indirect Loomer you
mean what did I say no I was just making
sure yes specifically
um Loomer specifically I mean because
Carrie Lake she probably wish she was on
on Donald Trump's team team
yeah his team right yeah okay
I got a little throw up in my mouth um
that's fine I think everyone did right
Laura Loomer says Carrie lake is hot
I hope I look this hot when I'm 53 this
really does seem like they're trying to
get out in front of this narrative that
Donald Trump is schlubbing Kerry Lake
they're like look not a big deal so what
if he's bone in the non-governor Gary
Lake she's hot
that's what it is we all knew he cheats
and right has uh but at least someone
who's hot right is that is that what is
that what this is
do you think that's what this is now I
wanna I wanna show
I want to show the
and the audience this uh blow up doll of
um Donald Trump that Carrie Lake on it
looks like it's on a boat now I haven't
confirmed where she was taking this boat
ride okay so it's unclear where she was
on this boat at but she was on a boat in
a swimming suit
and she if I can find it son of a [__]
I've been talking about this image of a
[__] I've been talking about this image
did I send you this I think I sent it to
you I don't know if I actually retweet
it I didn't want it on my Twitter
account maybe the one with the blow up
doll on the boat no I haven't when you
mentioned it and you brought up my photo
I was like that's not a blow up though I
have no idea what the blow up doll is I
haven't seen it you haven't seen this
thing no oh my God okay this is
it is um well let me see if I can find
it here see I [__] the bid on this wow
um you know it happens
um give me your and there the audience
is getting bigger as I'm as I'm going to
um oh they're growing just like the blow
up dog all right that's well
I don't know how much the blow up though
I don't know how realistic the blow up
doll is I'm just saying right
um
uh [__] [__] you want the link is
that what you're asking for yeah for the
what was that give me the link for what
was that why I'm trying to look track
down this uh Carey Lake
um
if I can find it I promise the audience
to uh show them this and uh rather they
want to see it or not
um what the [__] man I know I had it
I don't know if the audience knows this
but if you go to my timeline and you see
when I'm gonna show on the show
it's normally because I've retweeted it
like yeah that's that's the whole thing
now I've put it in the retweets here
um God damn now I can't find the son of
a [__] did I bookmark it maybe maybe
I'm not sure what you were doing this
morning when you when you found it I
what maybe what I'm just saying retrace
yourself
what what do you mean
that's all you got to do are you saying
that I might have been
possibly
is that what you're saying I look man I
don't I don't know what ideas you're
trying to blow up in your head there but
all you got to do is just replace your
steps on where you found this blow up
doll yeah I know God damn it
this is [__] ridiculous
this is [__] ridiculous here's what
we'll do we'll go watch the what was
that and we'll find how long is the what
was that hey nine minutes oh yeah 11
minutes It'll be plenty of time for me
not to find this um you know in terms of
this this this blow up doll picture so
here watch watch the what was that and
then we'll come back to this here is
Gabe's uh latest
um what was that on his uh his patreon
page let's go to what was that show.com
and you'll get exclusive access but here
it is here's the newest what was that
you know in terms of um you know
throughout history yeah I mean you know
I think like you know could I have been
there with Jesus's disciples wait what
was that you know in terms of um you
know throughout history yeah I mean you
know I think like you know could I have
been there with Jesus's disciples
[Music]
welcome back to another other episode of
what was that the show that leaves you
laughing at Humanity I'm your host Gabe
Sanchez and I've got a real gem for you
today our dear friend in Florida's
resident Android Ron DeSantis recently
made a rather well shall we say biblical
statement hold on to your Rosary folks
Ron DeSantis wishes that he had been a
part of Jesus Christ's Inner Circle you
have a favorite President is there is
there a president I heard something
about James Madison you like James
Madison is that right did I get my or is
I read it on the Internet it's got to be
true
geez can someone get this interview or
some holy water I feel like we're stuck
in an ASMR lip smacking video sorry
about that let's just fast forward to
the good stuff
you know in terms of um you know
throughout history yeah I mean you know
I think like you know could I have been
there with Jesus's disciples I mean you
know these are people who you know
Peter's Just Fishing one day and all of
a sudden this guy comes up to him
catches all the fish and says you know
you're going to be Fisher I want you to
be a fisher of men come with me and so
these guys all went out uh and they
dedicated their life to spreading the
gospel and they all were were killed for
you know they tried to kill John John
ended up you know being able to survive
but I mean the intent was to put him to
death too and you know to talk about
what that was like
um you know talk about what their what
their impressions are you know what are
that I look back at that and would love
to have been uh been able to be there
with them yep you heard that right Ron
DeSantis wants to be a member of Jesus
OG Posse you know giving Judas a real
run for his 30 pieces of silver now I
don't know about you but the idea of
Governor Ron DeSantis hanging out with
Jesus seems a bit far-fetched I mean can
you imagine to Santa sporting a robin
sandals watching Jesus cast out demons
and turn water into I don't know
chocolate pudding also I'm pretty sure a
follower of Christ let alone a disciple
of Christ would be 100 against the idea
of watching and laughing a prisoner
being tortured in Guantanamo Bay you
know just like our good old boy Ronnie
did I was bleeding because they really
insert the thick to you through my nose
so I was like calling them asking and
they he was actually laughing looking at
the other officers and smiling and let's
not forget that Rhonda Santos continues
to run on this idea that Florida is
where woke goes to die we must fight the
woke in our schools we must fight the
woke in our businesses we must fight the
woke in government agencies we can never
ever surrender to woke ideology and I'll
tell you this
the State of Florida is where woke goes
to die Florida is where woke goes to die
Florida is where woke goes to die
Florida is the state where woke goes to
die our state is where woke goes to die
here's the thing despite what
Republicans claim Jesus was actually
pretty damn woke Not only was Jesus a
refugee an immigrant to human rights
activist a fighter against
discrimination and injustices but the
guy grew up with two dads I mean Jesus
was so woke that one of his dads
literally awakened him from the dead and
when it comes to Ron DeSantis he is so
far from being Jesus homeboy the Florida
fascist is desperately trying to ban a
state out of existence come one come all
Florida has it all we've got book bands
we've got bathroom bands we've got
immigration bands and we've even got one
of the most extreme abortion bands in
America not sure about you but that
sounds like the complete opposite of
what Jesus would do and you know who
else claims to be followers of Jesus
Christ Christ that's right the
Republican party they never miss a
chance to remind us how devout they
really are but here's the thing when it
comes to caring about others and
following the word of God it's like they
conveniently misplace their Bible
honestly one of my biggest pet peeves is
how Republicans think they'd be BFFs
with Jesus despite their hateful
behavior and actions toward others I
mean these people are so disconnected
from the teachings of Christ that
they'll blame God for their own horrific
acts no I swear it was he the Lord
Almighty who guided my hand to write and
pass that legislation really God guided
you to attack marginalized communities
strip away their rights and treat them
like they were less than human I
wouldn't be surprised the Republicans
think that God guides them like Patrick
Swayze did with Demi Moore in ghost now
I'm no Theologian but I was raised
Catholic spent my entire childhood in
Catholic school and was involved in a
Christian Youth Group during high school
and look I have a lot of issues with the
church like
too many to go into detail right now in
this video but what I can tell you is
that in all the time I spent reading the
Bible and going to mass I'm pretty sure
that Jesus was all about helping the
poor Healing The Sick and being kind to
our neighbors however the GOP
interpreted those teachings as Thou
shalt hoard wealth dismantle social
safety nets and let the sick fend for
themselves and while Jesus preaches
compassion and love Republicans are all
about hate and building walls
figuratively and literally to keep the
undesirables out it's like they've
mastered the art of picking and choosing
which verses of the Bible to follow
hypocrisy thy name is the Republican
party now I'm not saying that all
Republicans are hypocritical Christians
just most of them but hey who am I to
judge I'm just a comedian pointing out
the absurdities of our political system
and trust me folks the hypocrisy meter
on this one is off the charts and one of
the biggest people cosplaying as a
republican Christian is none other than
Donald Trump to the religious right
Donald Trump can do no wrong hell he's
right up there with God I have great
relation relationship with God I have
great relationship with the evangelicals
these people made him into a golden
statue and prayed to it at CPAC 2021
which I'm pretty sure goes against the
whole golden calf story in Exodus oh and
how could I forget that one time in 2020
when Trump tear gas peaceful protesters
just so he could pose with a Bible in
front of a church Mounted Police have
been coming down the street you're going
to see him in the frame Now using
flashbangs in front of them and Mounted
Police to clear what has been an
entirely peaceful protest not 90 not 99
but 100 people protest here today
people throwing there was no throwing of
water bottles there was no throwing of
objects but a short time ago mounted
police officers have been clearing the
street don't worry folks I'm pretty sure
in the Book of John it talks about how
Jesus tear gas the town locals just so
he could heal that blind man Trump loves
God so much that he couldn't even be
bothered to bring his own Bible he just
got a random Bible from someone else and
then held it upside down like he was the
Antichrist
but here's the thing Trump has never
been religious in his life I mean the
guy pretended to be religious when he
ran as a republican in 2016. and when he
recently was asked about what his faith
means to him this is the word salad that
he spit out so I think a lot of uh
American conservative Believers
especially want to know is that what was
it like your faith is very important to
you you've said that publicly your faith
is important but what does that mean to
the man Donald Trump well I think it
means a lot of things but more to
perhaps your listeners than the people
that will watch this show and that's a
very large group of people uh for
instance I was the only president ever
go go to go to the big rally they had in
Washington right which they have on a
yearly basis but I was the only one ever
to go as a president sitting president
for life and people were shocked but
even Ronald Reagan didn't want to take
that step and it was very close always
very close as you know to the White
House it's almost like walking distance
but I went and I was proud of that and I
think we've been given credit for doing
that but some people would say that was
a courageous thing to do I didn't view
it as courageous I reviewed it as the
right thing to do but I was born into a
family where my father was religious my
mother was religious uh I wouldn't say
they were you know going to church every
single day but they were you know they
were Believers and and strong Believers
I went to Sunday school
which was good and which was expected
you know it was like you everybody goes
to start high school and when you think
about it the world is so different now
Sunday school is not uh probably on
everybody's key list and despite Trump
being a narcissistic racist lying sexual
assaulting grabbing serial adulterer
Republicans are okay with it I mean
they've completely compromised on the
very Ten Commandments that they claim to
live by and once again all of this is
the opposite of what Jesus would do and
a lot of it is preached by the very
people who claim to be the messengers of
God like Donald Trump's Evangelical
spiritual advisor Paula White strike and
strike and strike and strike and strike
and strike and strike and strike and
strike and strike until you have Victory
or like Maga Pastor Shane Vaughn God
spoke to me yesterday the minute I heard
the news he said if you don't get your
feet on the ground where he's gonna walk
I'll take my blessings off of you he
said I've called you to lift your voice
up and tell my people who my man is to
stand behind it to fight for him This Is
War
call me a trump worshiper all you want
to but I know what came from my trump
worship the blessings of the Lord when
you put your hand to the anointing the
anointing will put his hand to you
or like magalunatic Pastor can't
Christmas you want to know why the
mother
the month has had advancements is
because the Muslims were willing to die
for their believer they were willing to
strap bombs to their Chester they
believed in the afterlife God give us
some men and women now then I'll get a
hold of some passion in their spirit
that said I will lay down my life for
the gospel I think you get the point
unfortunately there's no shortage of
religious figures and Republican
lawmakers who claim to be loving
Christians but are actually just
Hypocrites they use religion to grift
off their supporters push their fascist
policies and then Shield themselves from
the horrible things that they do unto
others these people are not real
Christians and they certainly don't have
a great relationship with God well until
next episode I'm Gabe Sanchez and this
has been what was that if you enjoyed
today's episode and want to support the
work that goes into creating the what
was that show you can join my patreon at
what was that show.com you'll get access
to early episodes exclusive bits behind
the scenes content access to the show's
private Discord as well as live q and
A's to connect directly with me to offer
up comments questions and suggested
topics to be featured on the show thanks
again for watching and I hope to see you
over on patreon
so that was what was that oh man what a
great what was that that's a good I
think that's one of the best ones I've
seen
it really is that's what that's what
some people think you know who who knows
every every episode I try to do better
than the last like not all topics are
gonna be uh
uh as funny right I try to but that's
the whole point right that's the whole
point of what was that is I'm trying to
take uh an insane thing that happened or
an overly complicated thing that is and
I try to break it down
and also you know in in the way that it
kind of can help digest is that also
make jokes right right like you know
um
cathartic type of release is what their
goal is well I you know I noticed the
last Pastor that was yelling and
screaming is that is that Tom Fenton's
Uncle you know many people are saying I
got a really tiny yeah he's got he
looked I'm just saying he kind of looks
like
Tom Ben but the best part is the best
part of the whole thing I have to say is
is when the reporter asked Trump is that
your Bible it's a Bible I'll tell you
this that's actually the first okay so
one one of the First videos I think the
first video I ever made well not made
but like uh when I was making tick tocks
when I was like oh I'm gonna go into
this like political satire uh path
the first one I made was a video called
all arms matter right it was a critique
on all lives matter right right and it's
funny to if you go to the video on on my
YouTube You'll see people like oh good
there's oh why you got to make about
this it's like I'm making fun of you you
[__] idiot and the whole concept was
uh somebody like hurt their arm and they
were getting Band-Aids right right and
they're like hey we need to help this
person and then someone else like oh
what about my arm what about do I get a
Band-Aid and they're like well you hurt
and they're like well no and he's like
okay well this person's hurt right now
all arms matter yeah yeah right but then
the first video I think that I made past
that that was like all right I'm doing
I'm doing this I had a series that was a
uh white house uh
uh White House PR guy yeah and he had oh
yeah yeah that's right he would he would
yeah and so he would be in in the white
house and all the stuff and and that
would the first one I did was making fun
of Donald Trump or I was like just tell
him it's a Bible or it's it's your Bible
and he's like it's a Bible I'm like God
damn it
Ty says I think that's your best what
was that Gabe Gabe
okay I want to fulfill my promise but
before that I want to tell you you
should go to what was that show.com for
sure and at least check out what is
happening over there on patreon
um with all his exclusive access the
early episodes
um all the Q and A's that he's got over
there but you must if you're not gonna
do that it's free to go to his YouTube
channel so you got to go to Gabe just
search I am Gabe Sanchez on YouTube go
and subscribe to his YouTube channel you
will see those what was that you will
see his shorts you will see all his
political satire there
um once it is released to the public
free on the YouTube so go check that out
follow him on YouTube it's free to
follow him over there you might get um
some of the content after some other
folks on patreon but trust me it's worth
it you're going to want to see it I I
agree with Ty I think that's one of the
best what was that that you've done now
I want to fulfill my promise here
to the audience of this Trump blow up
doll and carry Lake I don't know what
she he's doing to it here
um do you think this is a blow up doll
right and I'm right though right this is
totally this is a is this real this is a
real I I mean you know it no this this
is [__] real this is real shut the
front door Tony now I don't know where
this is at or what but you know this
looks real to me it's real enough for me
to show that she's I don't know what
she's doing with the Trump blow up doll
but
a lot of people are getting like Tony
that's an inner tube she's on a boat
obviously it's just a gag for a picture
I you know it looks it you blow it up
it's a doll of trump it's a blow up doll
though here we go this is a good point
his hands are too big they are they are
well I mean I'm not saying that it's an
it's an accurate blood this isn't it
right exactly well listen if you do know
how to photoshop out there maybe you
should take this um photo and I'll
retweet it is this is this a [__]
pro-trump account I can't tell what is
it um hang on let me it's um
a little bit of parody
yeah but I've seen other right-wing
accounts that try to I mean click the
account let's see I stand with Donald
Trump
[Music]
let's see is there like uh I don't know
no I think this is this shop yeah I
think this is totally totally a manga
account it's got 830 000 followers
there's probably 90 of them are fake is
yeah it's a real store I stand with
Trump and then Legend and it's like him
with uh yeah so this is
this is that
um here I'll I'll I'll hear oh yep yep
holy [__] here it is of course it is
right there Carrie Lake now here's the
reason why I couldn't pull this up maybe
is because they might have me blocked
you can see I'm on the Pod account right
now see I'm on a pod account yeah that
may be why is because this morning
you uh found this picture of her and
Donald Trump smooching and that may that
may have prompted a lot of accounts to
block us I don't know I don't know could
be look I'm just saying I mean I know
Carrie lake has my my main account she
has me black she's had me black for a
while she had me blocked since the
Twitter space yeah when I think I
[__] I [__] with her after she said
Donald Trump it's not gonna have a
running mate yeah well her Fenton uh we
love you Seb we love you Sam dab you
[__] [__]
um so I don't know maybe that's why I
couldn't see it because they had me
blocked because it's possible
so but here here I'll live tweet from
the um because I you know I don't know
if I can tweet for my main account we'll
tweet from the podcast is that a blowout
is is that a trump
blow up doll
um
uh let's do the uh you think we should
do the puke face is that the is that the
face we should have in there
pull up there you go is that good is
that a trump blow up doll I'm just
saying or should I say a sheep [__] a
trump blow up bullet ah you know
and let's just let's go with this I
don't wanna I don't want to get two out
right just so there it is if you want
the picture of Carrie I mean it looks
pretty though it really looks pretty
close to that other photo I found and
Carrie Lake confirmed it if you're not
sure if this is real
look right there
right there I love you right back like
literally she what the [__] man she's
[__] sending I love you messages to a
trump
parity account yeah that's [__] weird
isn't it
would you find I don't know if Katie
Hobbs would do this Maybe I'm Wrong
then maybe that's why she's Governor
Kerry is because she's not she's a
serious person that could be it who
knows uh let's see I also want to make
sure that I give them credit ah your
tweets well you gotta your Tweet sucks
okay um so should we go do bone end of
the week what are we gonna be doing in
the week who do we have yeah sure why
not tell me I mean let's yeah well we
got we we did it a little different this
week now there could be some overlap
but the the the options were
not people not people not places they
were just things things they were like
groups right right so we had the GOP
correct the Supreme Court uh-huh
and also Fox News well some [__] so so
that was the um moment of the weeks and
I don't know
it may or may have not have been a
moderator named MJ that came up with
this um
with this I I think it's a great idea to
be frank it kind of It kind of shakes
things up who's Frank huh who's Frank
Frank what do you think
and well they're sure why not all right
sure why not why not
oh my God it may or may have not been
the great moderator MJ that came up with
this idea I think it's a great idea they
were here's what happened I don't know
if you guys know this
Thursday
only because it gets later uh in the
evening when we get the bone out of the
week because that's how time works it
gets right we hey [__] you
we um
we may or may not forget about the
um to put the poll up right moderators
moderators would normally come in and
remind us because we have many great
moderators here by the way give them
love in the chat while you're here
whether you're here on our Channel
you're over on the up wires Channel or
you're on Twitch give the moderators
some love in the chat and they normally
remind us they're like hey stupid the
poll isn't up which then we're like oh
yeah but yesterday to be fair yesterday
me and you were texting back and forth
and I text bone net of the week question
mark
and I just gave one answer you gave one
answer and I thought it was a great
answer by the way yeah yeah then then
um moderators Who Shall Not Be Named MJ
um reminded us and made this suggestion
that maybe we should change it up this
week and I think it's a great idea so I
am I am giving MJ the the credit
um of this idea now I'm also giving you
the blame so if you hate this why not
why not go talk to the moderators about
this one no I'm just kidding
um I think it's a great idea to shake up
bone of the week so let's do it let's go
to break when we come back we'll have
the brand new and improved not persons
but but groups of people still still a
noun right and if we want to get into
pronouns we can talk about that later oh
yeah they them instead of HE yeah and
her maybe yeah okay well after this
break
we're gonna bring you bonehead of the
week stick around we'll be right back
right after this
[Music]
mark
Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show you have
reached Friday June 13th so what Friday
is
podcast on Friday
we go over your vote you vote you decide
who is the bonehead of the week
me and Gabe Sanchez break it down right
here in the second hour of the Tony
Michaels podcast and we are in bonehead
of the week
that's how we always finish the week off
is boner of the week
don't know great who don't know it is
it's always a good finish
it's always a good you know we finish
like the best yeah we do
oh so those you don't know bone of the
week you used to be a weekend show that
we did when we only had one show a week
and then when we went to every single
weekday Monday through Friday for two
full hours we took the bonehead show and
we put it as a segment on Friday because
we figured it in the show it's fun
segment we really like it it engages the
audience because you get to vote you get
to decide
who is the bonehead of the week here's
how you do it Gabe is you go to our
YouTube channel okay
and you subscribe to our YouTube channel
if you're there right now subscribe you
can go to the community tab you just
scan over the community Tab and the poll
is there it's almost like a Twitter on
YouTube sort of yeah kinda yeah exactly
but kind of like yeah we should post
more [__] over there yeah yeah we should
um but you know
time is of the essence okay so you can
vote there or you can vote on Twitter
you can vote on Twitter at Tony
Michael's Pond every single Thursday
night when the moderators remind us to
put up the poll and Gabe finally gets it
together and asks me hey are these good
I'm like yeah that's good go ahead and
put it up but yesterday
um someone suggested MJ
that we
the great moderator MJ did you did you
know this Gabe that MJ has been around
before you were here did you know that
like Kim Jay MJ was watching this show
when there was like eight people
watching like there would be eight
people watching the entire time were you
two of them were me one of them was MJ
like every [__] time and back then it
was once a week but now it's every
single day but she is OG [__] fam
like OG and and and
um MJ can tell you
um like who else was there because she
literally she's like no there was five
people there there's
there was this person this person this
person and this person was there
watching so that's how far we've come
since the very beginning of the Tony
Michaels podcast is we went from five or
six eight people watching to now we have
almost two thousand yesterday was 2500
people watching so it's it's grown it's
grown
huge
huge and the bone of the week is one of
the reasons now this was the bone of the
week was originally your idea because
you're like you should do like a weekend
thing yeah I'm like all right that
sounds good we should do a weekend thing
what should we do and you're like hey
that bonehead thing that you say you
always say bonehead let's play off that
I'm like yeah sure what what do you got
you're like we should do a poll every
week on Twitter it would Engage The
Audience I'm like yeah that's great yeah
people love the button head hole I said
let's do bone-headed leak let's do a
competition yeah where we put three
people against each other they're always
going to be boneheads which means
99.9 of the time they're gonna be
fascist Republicans which is great for
us I mean they're really leaning into
that these days it's easy to mock them
and this was after this was after Lauren
Margie Taylor green was part of their
caucus Matt gants and the others Jim
Jordan Jim Comer I mean Donald Trump it
was perfect absolutely perfect but we've
never done what we what we've done this
week yeah which the boneheads are not
people that you were voting on they're
not people I mean they they there are
people in these right institutions if
you want to go out there right okay are
these organizations yeah right the
groups they're composite of all of these
valuable things each of these things
that we put in they them uh are a
composite a cluster [__] of fascists
right and some some of these groups
don't have all fascists yes now this
morning one of these groups this morning
there there was a great decision that
came out of the Supreme Court let me
just show you the the bonehead uh picks
this week so you got the you got to
choose and vote who is the moment of the
week rather it's GOP Supreme Court and
Fox News this is kind of an easy one
yeah I mean I know the way I voted and
I'll tell you I voted GOP although I
voted for Donald Trump wait what well I
mean yeah there was I think there was a
lot there's always a lot of people
um in the comments that are like oh no
it's it's usually three names to be
quite honest yeah it's Donald Trump
Lauren bobert and Marjorie Taylor green
like they're like oh well they're and
some people get mad when we put them on
the poll because they're like look you
got to take them off the pole because
they're just not even in the same
bone-headed universe yeah as these other
folks
Stratosphere right compete with each
other right exactly exactly but these
are these were your your options
GOP Supreme Court and Fox News so let's
I always like to play the music so let's
play the music and then we'll get into
mocking the boneheads of the week
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to this edition of bonehead of
the week again we have a special edition
here because we have a groups of folks
boneheads that are
um in the running for bonehead of the
week GOP the Supreme Court in Fox News
okay Fox News Fox News Fox News so let's
start with [__] let's start with Fox
News why why did Fox News make its way
on monetta link you think
I mean I'm sure there's a lot of reasons
uh right uh you know some might say it
was for platforming Donald Trump but
then you could be like oh well they put
him up there and they they exposed him
right
um I'm trying to remember was there a
specific reason that Fox News was on
here well I mean here's the thing is
that Fox News did platform him but at
the same time I think the reason why Fox
News did not win this poll yeah is
because they did a fairly decent job as
in Brett Bear of really
disarming Donald Trump
um there but it's still platforming him
right did you see well here there's a
clip actually of Jesse Waters let me see
if I can find oh yeah great you know
what Fox News is always on the list of
boneheads because they still have Jesse
waters on the air yeah yeah he tried to
that's enough to be the bonehead of the
century alone yeah if you guys aren't
aware if you guys don't watch Fox News
which you probably don't I don't even
watch it I don't even watch CNN or
anything SMBC I mean I watched the clips
of the garbage and then I wonder why the
[__] do people watch this why do you
even turn this [__] on like and I'll
listen to uh you know admittedly almost
I'll listen to Morning Joe
um usually Mondays sometimes other days
when I'm hungover when I just I
I need a little bit of stimulation for
the news
I'll listen to Morning Joe but half the
time I'm yelling at the people on
Morning Joe because they're not telling
saying the [__] like they need to be
saying right their narrative is all
[__] wrong and I hope we can get into
which I know we are gonna get into the
Titanic thing today in bonehead of the
week yeah and this is actually related
so it's going to touch on that briefly
great maybe we can switch to that when
we do it and then go back since it's
kind of in you know not conventional
bonehead of the week yeah yeah
is it the Jesse is it Jesse Waters
talking about the um yeah he I'm trying
to find it I know I know media has it
but I can't load the [__] video on
you yeah are you blocked I'm having more
and more trouble on Twitter because I
keep getting blocked and Twitter is such
a [__] dumpster fire
it really is it's like it's not working
worth this [__] it's almost like elon's
running out of money or something it's
it's almost like that yeah it's almost
like that guy is on the phone I mean
look it's uh it definitely definitely
someone that I would say uh earned maybe
a position this week on bonehead of the
week yeah absolutely but also there's a
whole story about that which I want to
go into which is this whole like do you
have extra time because we're we're at
the bottom of the second yeah yeah I got
a little extra time good good it sounds
like for the audience's
um uh pleasure we are gonna go over two
hours today which we do sometimes and go
over I cannot find this clip aren't you
[__] serious what clip is it maybe
Jesse Waters talking about Ocean Gate
okay and it's funny that Jesse Waters
I know
it also goes into this whole like recent
conspiracy theory that they developed
last night or the last two days oh my
God it's so [__] hilarious okay
um is it this is
talking to G Michael Harris
uh more people have been in outer space
in the depths of the ocean
um Jesse Waters retweeted this thing
here I'll send you I'll send you the
article because I can't find it on uh on
Twitter I know it's on there but I can't
find it anyway here's the link so this
is uh Jessica you know what you might
find uh go to uh decoding Fox News she
might have it oh yeah she's always got a
lot of Jesse Waters
let's see if I can does this does this
meteorite clip have the yeah it's got
the it's got the clip at the top it's
got the clip at the top
maybe I don't know
it looks like I gotta subscribe to watch
it are you sure no no no oh there it is
hey easy easy easy
okay here it is let's watch this clip oh
Jesse
he's been telling me that for a long
time okay here we go been alluding to or
or the dangers and and the one of the
passengers who's on it now said before
you even get on the boat there's a long
long waiver that mentions death three
times on page one do you think the
passengers really took that seriously or
did they look at it as just another
casual waiver you know that you sign at
a doctor's office wait wait is she
asking Jesse to give a serious answer is
that what she's asking and Jesse looking
at the camera waiting he's waiting he's
like oh I'm gonna yeah this is gonna be
it I mean surely this is going to be
just enlightening it's like the it's
like that uh that scene in How the
Grinch Stole Christmas right and then it
it slowly goes
when is his smile yeah I can't do I
can't do a smile like that Jim Carrey's
pretty good at like yeah that's all
that's all natural man right okay let's
listen to
um mcchuckle [__] here give us the um
give us the enlightenment on
the judges
judge box lines question is this [__]
real life that these people pretend to
do this [__]
yep and this is yeah and this is like oh
we're serious see see on our show we
don't like make bones about it we're not
like we're not trying to like [__]
you know present you the serious news in
a serious way like we're trying to
present it to you in a way that will
entertain you they're actually they're
pretending to be serious yeah and
they're not being serious but let's
let's try it out let's
see if we can take a walk around this
playground do you always read the fine
print on the waiver I usually don't
that's why I don't sign waivers usually
pretty sure he just said when I sign
waivers I don't read it that's why I
don't which is it [__] also it's
also the idea that he's like I don't
sign waivers okay well then I guess you
can't do the things that require you to
sign a waiver right right it didn't so
you're not reading them if you don't I
mean did you sign a waiver at Fox News
when you got a vaccine right well I
think they did he did he read it then I
don't know I guess not I guess not is it
is it because he doesn't want to read it
or is it because he can't read well or
that he doesn't want people to know the
truth about him that he's a creepy
scumbag who slashes people's tires yeah
yeah to meet them in parking lots well
it's not no no hold on hold on there's
more to that story it's he slashes
women's tires so they need a ride home
and that woman was one of the like
assistant producers on the show while he
was still married to his wife and had a
family with two kids I think yeah that
is how he met his wife and he told this
story
he said this he told us this on the five
he's like oh that's how I met my uh and
everyone's like oh what I'm not I'm not
committing defamation here I'm just
what do you want me to do let's listen
to this creep talk about how he doesn't
sign waivers even though he signs them
but when he doesn't read them but he
doesn't sign I don't know who knows if
there's a waiver involved I don't sign
it and I don't participate in the
activity this is like Evil Knievel for
the ocean even 10 times more dangerous
and the CEO has a very Cavalier attitude
when it comes to safety there's been
lawsuits there's been accusations about
slashing regulations he's quoted as
saying he didn't so is Jesse Waters now
pro-regulation I'm confused because I'm
starting to agree with Jesse Watterson I
know and this is I don't like this clip
Gabe Sanchez just wait for it just wait
oh okay okay okay maybe there's maybe
there's more to this third way through I
know I know I just I just want to bring
this up
of course it is we're going to get to
the slashing the tires thing here soon
he's like no no I wanted to give her a
ride I wanted to give her a ride it was
just that I was a nice guy giving a ride
I forget the fact that I'd slashed your
tires so that way she had to have a ride
and right I would creepily swoop in like
the superhero that I want to appear to
be I'm sure that moment's coming let's
oh yeah and hire a bunch of 50 year old
white guys with military experience
because he didn't want his vessels to be
not inspirational for a younger
generation
I don't care who is in these vessels I
just want them to be experienced and
safe and if you're going to be woke you
might have to
I don't want to say it because I don't
want to put these people's legacies
through that but
I don't see how they're ever going to
find this thing again did did he say did
he say woke is that what is that what he
said wait yeah if you're gonna be woke
wait
here's the thing here's the thing is
that we are accused from time to time of
being mother wokers like I've been
accused of being woke
and I recall this entire week I actually
have
a lot of flack in the chat about my
insensitivity of these rich dummies
getting in a beer can and sinking
themselves to the bottom of the ocean
and dying of their own accord and be
dancing on their graves doing it
how in the [__] is any of this woke
explain that to me I don't know play the
clip play it back just so everyone can
hear him saying again he said it he said
because he stops himself and he was like
oh no gotta gotta redirect that's not
what I'm trying to say it's not woke
woke would be if there were regulations
right let's listen see your old white
guys with military experience because he
didn't want his vessels to be
not inspirational for a younger
generation
I don't care who is in these vessels I
just want them to be experienced and
safe and if you're going to be woke you
might have to
I don't want to say it because I don't
want to put these people's legacies
through that but
I don't see how they're ever going to
find this thing again oh boy that's a
sad thought and you know Greg
um Ocean Gate yeah let's go to Greg
let's go to the government now be
involved in let's go to Greg I'm sure
Greg has a much much more Advantage yeah
I'm sure he has a much more advanced
um they're like oh they're like I'm sure
in their in their earpieces they're like
he said well redirect that's not the
argument we're trying to make or or
they're like or they're like how did you
get woke in that word salad man go to
Greatness that's probably why he's
they're like did you say woken and he
like stopped he's like I've got to stop
myself before I say anything that you
know uh tarnishes their legacy
I wouldn't be surprised if he said woke
and the people in the booth are like
what and he was like and you heard it
out and then he was like wait what did I
just say right it's just they're so used
to saying woke yeah they can't help it
they're like oh this is horrible so it's
woke like I don't like this makes me
gives me bad feelings so it's woke but
let's see what let's see what Greg gut
Bell has say I'm sure it's just
inspirational what that [__] idiot
has to say oh Explorations at this level
uh on all protocols and inspection going
forward I I mean I don't know I mean the
great thing about Ocean Gate gate
see what I did there is that
dude I made that joke four days ago a
lot better than you did you [__]
idiot he's horrible at this man he's
horrible at this you would never put
gate on it's already there man the night
it literally it's called the controversy
of what it would right and and I I said
was it Tuesday I said are they are they
calling it that or is that the actual oh
yeah when you asked me because I was
like because I was like
no I know I know it's that [__] me up
man that [__] me up I mean when I mean
you know it's one of those self-filling
prophecies when you name the thing
that's people are gonna call right it
when it's like oh look at this
controversy
didn't didn't the uh you know speaking
of that didn't the owner the guy who who
um was in this craft well didn't he say
that this submarine was Unsinkable yeah
I get an interview he said the word you
know what they said they said that about
the Titanic too Tony okay they said that
about the Titanic too and look what
happened to that it's not like they're
going down to the bottom of the ocean to
see an unsinkable ship or anything right
what the [__] these people are all
[__] brain dead I just want to point
out Greg Gutfeld you know because
he does have well there's only one late
night show that's on the air right now
and Greg Gutfeld is that show and his
writers crossed the picket line uh and I
don't even I'm assuming they're probably
Union but they've crossed yeah but did
they because are they comedy writers are
they no they're little they're not
comedy writers but I think because they
are I think they're consider are part of
the Union anyway they are because it's
in New York yeah so he he has a team of
writers he does the show every night and
uh he's the number one late night comedy
show right and I use air quotes like Don
Jr here so
uh Greg Gutfeld right supposedly he's
conservative comedian really telling it
like it is you know the fact that he has
to go Ocean Gate gate you see what I did
there if you're a comedian
you don't have to explain what the punch
line
it shouldn't have yeah you shouldn't
have to right I mean obviously
Republicans and that demographic might
not be so Keen to jokes or understanding
what they are especially shitty ones
yes so Jim Williams says scabs for the
writers oh they're scabs all right it
scabs in many ways than
right
is Tony is Tony Frozen
in the chat is Tony Frozen
I'm not frozen
I don't even know if he's trying to talk
right now
yes okay oh Tony imploded okay we've now
taken over my plan to take over the show
is complete
he said his [__] just dropped which
means it's just me but for the sake of
Tony in memory
we're going to keep Tony up on the
screen
keep telling me up on the screen over
here so just just let yeah people people
want to people are saying uh thaw him
out thaw him out for sure uh I don't
have a screamer so I gotta load up my
screen keep going that's what Tony says
he says keep oh now he definitely
dropped okay cool all right so anyway
now that Tony's gone let's talk [__]
about this guy okay uh no no okay but
yes
let's quickly just talk about Ocean Gate
okay you had uh you know an hour and 45
minutes into oh [__] he's back God damn
it oh God damn it oh no me off
no I didn't get you here
[__] Heaven dude you froze you were like
I was talking and then you were like
and then I was like is it me is Tony and
then I had to wait for the chat to tell
me my [__] just went blank like my
computer's like [__] you I'm out yeah
many people are saying that I I planned
it and and many people are saying that
it was a a Cheeto chop
I got you
so should we finish this uh video then
uh uh
uh Jesse or did we go far enough I don't
know no that's far enough because here's
what we'll do we'll go we'll come back
on to Ocean Gate
because yeah well let's do that let's do
that because we yeah okay all right
yeah Ocean Gate here yeah and this is
the dishonorable mention
um his name is Stockton Rush yeah which
that's enough to make you question any
decision he makes really honestly I mean
is that fair enough am I am I or am I I
mean it would make me be like
uh building of this device right I mean
they cut Corners they didn't get it a
class for for safety and I mean let me
find the clip of
um yeah we played several of these no no
there's another clip there's another
there is all the other day oh fantastic
here we go here we go here we go I got
it I got it I got it yeah this is the
machine reason why
Stockton Rush this is why I chose well
when Tony asked me yesterday he said hey
who bonehead of the week question mark
and I said CEO of Ocean Gate LOL and
that's and that's who this guy is if it
wasn't for MJ I would have only made
stuff it would have just been this would
just be stuck in rush because here's the
thing this [__] idiot
and I call him a [__] idiot because
he's not an innovator he's not a an
entrepreneur and not a thought leader
he's just a [__] [__] I called him I
called him a wish.com Elon Musk this
morning yeah he is honestly but he is a
wish.com I mean literally I think he was
buying [__] for this craft off wish.com
literally this guy because he was buying
[__] off Amazon I mean the light that's
above him the controller the screens
everything he's like oh you can buy
these as like third-party components and
it's like they're all stock items man we
built this whole thing did you know is
and maybe this is what this is so I'm
not gonna blow it here but let's watch
this clip that you see in here of the
CEO of Ocean Gate
who is now imploded at the bottom of the
ocean in his homemade beer can the
former CEO of ocean wow that's true he
is I mean you know you know what they
say you you can't get
well I guess you can get ocean but you
can't get ocean without CEO right I
guess so floods oh my God
oh for [__] sake let's listen to
Stockton Rush here just uh drape Us in
intelligence I'd like to be remembered
as an innovator
you remembered for the
for them you know I've broken some rules
to make okay okay okay dude the rules
you broke were the laws of physics okay
that these aren't rules that you
necessarily want to break what
MacArthur's just just wait wait for the
next part because this is this is the
specifics of what most likely uh led to
well
the crushing of the beer again that's
why I call it a beer can by the way
because that's really in my mind you
know when you just put an empty beer can
on the asphalt yeah and then you I mean
you stomp on it like you jump in the air
to stop yeah right that's what I
envisioned happened to him but let's say
let's listen let's listen this I think
I've broken them with with logic and
good engineering behind me carbon fiber
and titanium there's a rule you don't do
that well I did I'd like to be
remembered let's listen to it again yeah
I think it was General MacArthur said
you remembered for the rules you break
and you know I've broken some rules to
make this I think I've broken them with
with logic and good engineering behind
me the carbon fiber and titanium there's
a rule you don't do that well I did
okay no there's a reason you don't do
that because literally you have to
withstand the pressure
when you submerge an object into the
ocean well well you're acting as if
there is a lot of pressure down at the
bottom of the ocean look I know it's
almost like there's um what are these
things called facts
and you need to stop with your facts
Gabe Sanchez the fact that he was the
fact that he was like oh you're supposed
to build with this you can't do it with
fiberglass I mean does anyone people
know I don't know no no carbon fiber
oh right sorry
yeah yeah yeah yeah which again I mean
I've used carbon fiber on uh when I used
to row in high school in college we had
carbon fiber shelled boats right but
those were [__] open and no one was
planning to go underwater with them so
you know what is
also crazy there's a story this morning
of where he bought some of his carbon
fiber and titanium pieces was it Russia
no no it was Boeing it's an American
company Boeing he bought them from
Boeing and he bought them at a discount
guess why because they were defective no
they were past their shelf life
I'm not cheating you okay I'm not
cheating you this is listen this is like
again a beer can but if but if Bud Light
made a queer beer that was re the can
was really thin like really thin not
like normal aluminum then like really
thin and then you stepped on it and
crushed it that's what this is like it's
Insanity that anyone would get and you
know the smartest [__] on this
craft was the kid was the kid with the
dad the the rich Pakistani yeah family
apparently the kid's like I don't want
to go on your father's day trip
[__] something wrong is gonna
happen like he was the smartest one wow
what does that tell you oh my God but
yes you know what it does tell me it
tells me uh if you're a man and you've
got money yeah you most likely
have a very fragile ego and you need to
try to prove everyone wrong even if that
means trying to disprove the laws of
physics right you're like [__] you
Newton and your goddamn Three Laws like
[__] you crazy
laws of physics anyways but again you
know you know what I bet they're woke as
[__] those laws of physics probably I
mean as soon as that Apple fell off that
tree hit Newton in the head he was like
oh what and the the Apple was like I'm
woke as [__] and also I got these three
laws and Newton was like oh what you're
talking Apple [__] man that's pretty
woke and then he told him what the three
laws were and here we are today and
people try to [__] change those
things and how you should you know it's
like oh I don't have to I don't have to
obey the laws of physics well you kind
of do okay right you kind of you do do
you know how we know that this excursion
wasn't woke
uh it's for Jesse Waters if he's wanting
to know the onion has it here
because
the youngins headline
critics say submersible should have been
tested with poor passengers first oh my
God
um you know what in the world of reality
that's exactly how it would have been
done yeah
um you know and speaking of um alternate
realities
the right well it's almost I mean you
know for them they'd be like oh yeah
it's how we like uh it's how we like
test things right you know it's it's
like there's
I don't know a reason that we have
regulations not that we test them on
poor people but we have tests that we
conduct before we put human life right
that's like when you're doing FDA trials
there's clinical trials and then you
test on things that are not human and
then the third phase there's three
phases that happen when you're like hey
I've got this new pharmaceutical drug
I've got this new thing and I want to
make sure that it's okay for the human
masses
you go through two initial phases before
the FDA is like yeah that's good okay
great okay we've looked over the
paperwork and the data and the research
and it seems good we have now approved
you
to go on to human trials
that's the last phase before you get it
approved so you're saying what they
should have done is not sent poor people
down there maybe like just something
that would emulate humans and see if it
would work yeah something I mean you
could you could put a gelatin body I
mean they did it or just test it yeah
whatever man that's that's one of the
the
um
the examples and I think on that example
of Mythbusters it was like 135 PSI yeah
they put it in they put a gelatin body
inside a pig yeah like Pig carcass
inside the so to see what would happen
to a human right if they would undergo
that much pressure there's 135 PSI yeah
it was bad it was bad like it was really
bad but the experience that these
[__] experienced was like five
thousand to six thousand PSI like it
would take 30 milliseconds to just pop
them like a grape yeah if you want to
have some sort of uh image there but
Jack prostate here
I can't believe he still does not have
me blocked this is disappointing
honestly you sent me this last night and
then I immediately went to the Wall
Street Journal article and then pulled
up the quotes from the statement right
and you sent them to me and they're the
exact opposite of what they're saying
yeah so the right wing this morning Ben
Shapiro's on this and I tweeted at him
too the right wing is really [__]
pissed off that a a wish.com Elon Musk
convinced a bunch of Rich dummies to get
inside of a beer can throw some cinder
blocks around it go to the bottom of the
ocean okay they're really pissed off
about that so pissed off that they're
they're blaming it on Brandon how dare
you Brandon like that's literally what
they're saying here's Jack prostate he
says holy shlit now I don't know if he
misspelled it or he's just such a
snowflake that he can't type out [__] on
the freedom of speech platform like
Twitter come on man get a [__] set of
nuts would you just type [__] you idiot
God damn or learn how to spell [__] okay
I'll move on here I digress from that he
says that Wall Street Journal is
reporting that U.S Navy detected the
Titans implosion on Sunday which is sort
of true but they're fighting but very
very very very very very loose they
detected what could have been right it
was an anomaly it was an anomaly in
sound because they were recording all
sounds the Navy the Navy not the Coast
Guard it's almost like there's a reason
that we do that because we're trying to
detect maybe I don't know where it is
yeah where it is but also like trying to
you know be like oh there's a threat
that that's out there in the water
somewhere right right exactly but it
goes on to say but Biden
held the news until Tuesday's
whistleblower testimony on Hunter
so everything listen if you're not
understanding how mind [__] these
people actually are
this idiot is is actually putting out
there in the universe and it's all
right-wingers today and the media is
placating into this stupid [__] I don't
know if you watch MSNBC this morning or
CNN or definitely Fox News they're
they're definitely playing into the
hands of this narrative this stupid
narrative about how the U.S Navy
detected an anomaly now what happened
here's what happened and well he says
the entire thing is a distraction of it
so they're saying that this incident in
the out in in the ocean near the
Titanic's wreckage
um off the coast of Newfoundland is a
distraction from the hunter Biden
[__] plea deal what the [__] are you
people yapping about yeah now it's got
it has uh Twitter notes here right about
it it and it says that the U.S or the
Wall Street journalist does not did
report that the US Navy heard that but
it does not report that Biden held the
news let alone any reasoning for it it's
really stupid um I said thanks Obama
I don't know what else I mean what else
are you supposed to say thank you yeah
there's nothing really else that you can
say other than the fact of like these
people are trying to
destroy I mean like it's funny that
they're like oh man they're trying to
distract the news it's all distraction
up it's like what do you think you're
doing right now like right you're
distracting your District you are the
one distracting from other things right
like
the fact that the hunter Biden did plead
two crimes and they did investigate him
and the [__] that you're saying about
him and Joe Biden none of that [__] was
evidence in the criminal investigation
from the United States Attorney who was
[__] appointed by Donald Trump in
Delaware to to [__] put Hunter Biden
and Joe Biden in jail you dumb
[__] man and and we're coming
off the heels of an embarrassing
embarrassing oversight committee
appearance with John Durham yes where
they're like look at the Durham report
and the Democrats like okay right yeah
and the response was oh we got Accenture
Adam Schiff right we gotta do this we
gotta do that it's all a psyop and
they're trying to distract us from the
hunter Biden whistleblower
is this person real
is this person does this person actually
exist and was this person actually in
the role that they claim to be a part of
right because I think they said it was
an IRS agent that was overseen listen if
you got an IRS whistleblower that's
saying yes Hunter Biden did cheat on his
taxes he did pay the money that he owed
because he cheated on his taxes and now
he's being criminally charged in a
federal court from a United States
Attorney by pleading guilty to two
misdemeanor charges of this said crime
that he committed to the IRS then yeah
that's what are you whistleblowing what
are you [__] He's pleading guilty
right to two I mean this this this like
supposed whistleblower this IRS agent
like has been saying this stuff since
April
so the recent news about what like the
last time I read about it was April 20th
and then I saw today that there was more
news about this whistleblower and I was
like what like is there anything like if
I look up yeah but but Ben Shapiro here
wants you to believe that the reason why
that they sent this submersible and
killed these rich people who pay 250 000
to be part of this this psyop to make
sure that Hunter by news and the Durham
report didn't get out there he's so
[__] stupid literally the day that we
talked about this the first time I led
the story in with the hunter Biden deal
with the hunter Biden plea deal I did 30
minutes on it we talked to Texas Paul
about it it wasn't until the end of the
show until we talked about the stupid
[__] submersible but here bench
Shapiro says hard to think of a better
way oh my gosh to undermine
institutional credibility than to spend
days pretending that the submersible may
be at the bottom of the ocean it was at
the bottom of the ocean and that the
entire world should hold its breath they
work well
they weren't holding their breath
because they didn't have any bread to
hold yeah I'm not talking about the
world I'm talking about the dumb
[__] at the bottom of the ocean
while knowing for days the thing
imploded that's not the truth here's the
truth the Navy the United States Navy
the Canadian Navy the French navy were
on the scene with equipment trying to
help the Coast Guard in their search and
rescue effort yeah the Coast Guard was
in charge of the search and rescue
effort and the reason why I gave Sanchez
it be because that's what the Coast
Guard does okay that is what they do now
what the Navies do whether it's U.S Navy
French or the Canadian Navy is they have
a lot of equipment to detect a lot of
[__] in the water sometimes explosions
are implosions in the water they do it
by sonar they pick up sounds they record
those sounds on Sunday the United States
saying these are the facts the United
States Navy
recorded a sound in the water that
seemed like an anomaly and it could be
an implosion they didn't know they don't
know all they have is the the sound that
happened that's it and they have to make
conclusions just based on that there was
no other fact they actually on Sunday
gave Sanchez they let the command of the
Coast Guard who is in charge of the
search and rescue know about this
implosion sound and approximately where
it was and the reason why they would do
that is because if it was the ship it
might give the Coast Guard and the
command of the Coast Guard a direction
of where it might be that they could
find this ship the command of the Coast
Guard did the thing they always do with
protocol is not call off the search and
rescue because it was not enough
evidence yeah to say that this is
definitively this ship and it wasn't
until yesterday when the proper
equipment received on the scene that
they could get to the sea floor to
confirm term that yes parts of this
craft are on the sea floor which means
that that sound on Sunday was them
popping like a grape more than likely
which yesterday LED them to confirm that
yeah they're [__] right they've been
[__] for a while but we continue to
search in case they weren't [__] right
because we didn't know for sure until we
saw the [__] at the bottom of the sea
and the other took a while to get the
equipment there to confirm it exactly
and the other aspect of this is the idea
that they're like oh you know Jack
prostate wants to make you believe like
oh Biden knew about this and it was all
distraction tactic and this and this and
that however
that would imply that they knew
immediately right that they're like oh
we detected something on Sonar and we
happen to know that that thing imploded
like it was that very exact thing that
was in the water
and let's also remember
that Ocean Gate didn't notify anyone
until I don't know it was like eight
hours later
so they were like oh [__] [__] [__] it's
like it's like that moment when you like
drop something in the kitchen or you
break something at your house and you're
trying to hide it from your parents like
oh [__] [__] [__] and you're like trying
to clean it up so your parents don't
know this is like that moment they go
missing eight hours go by which means
they're like oh [__] uh okay okay uh uh
uh anyone like they're trying to test
systems they're trying to like see if we
can get through they're trying to you
know see if there's anything that they
can they can spot nearby if there's any
floating like rummage on the top of the
surface or if they've detect anything on
their own sonar
they were there for eight hours trying
to figure it out before they said okay
okay we're at the point of no return and
we have to we have to report this to the
Coast Guard
and we have to figure out what's going
on because we are now outside
of our realm of expertise we do not have
the equipment we do not have the
expertise
and we might have just killed these
people
right
wow so and so with this whole idea that
they withheld [__] it's like they heard
a sound they didn't know and even the
company that was in charge didn't tell
them until a [__] third of a day
later well and nor did the United States
Navy the Canadian Navy the French navy
nor the Coast Guard want to have to do
this search and rescue operation this
was not planned by the Biden
Administration you [__] fools and
really honestly it's more stupid
conspiracy theories like gay frogs and
queer beer and Target's gonna Turn You
Gay so keep going dummies keep going and
honestly if you want to make this this
story that was in all of social media
which all people were mocking up
Millionaires and billionaires and and I
want to give you a video here to to show
you this
um someone posted this from Tick Tock
and I think yeah it was our friend
Justin t Brown found this and posted
this
um that he found on Twitter if you want
to know something about why we were
mocking them here here's here's a good
here's a good uh Diddy about it if you
see people making jokes about the
submarine and it's making you a little
upset I want you to know that you should
be upset
you should be upset but I don't want you
to stop there I don't want you to stop
at being upset that there are some folks
that are laughing at another human
being's despair
I want you now to ask the next question
right don't get intellectually lazy now
ask the next question what could have
possibly happened
in this these last 100 years
to create a condition where millions of
working-class people had almost no
empathy for a billionaire in despair
what could have happened it can't just
be that poor people are just angry and
jealous like don't get don't get
intellectually lazy now you ask the
question go all the way figure the whole
thing out where could this lack of
empathy come from maybe is it could it
be that poor and middle class lower
class people see the wealth that their
labor creates being profiteered on at
Nero oligarchy levels so much so that
they themselves are paywalled from the
very things that their labor is supposed
to provide them like Health Care like
education like access to education their
living conditions are being commodified
to to such an extreme level that they
don't even know if they can live in the
places that they grew up in and all of
this is happening at the hands of
millionaires and billionaires that are
taking too much from what they're not
creating could it be that we literally
just went through a global pandemic and
watched Millionaires and billionaires on
corporate earning calls brag about
raising the prices of basic Goods to
rake in record profits when we needed
them the most you're seeing these jokes
online and you think that people are not
nice but the truth is people are not
dumb large corporations CEOs and
billionaires fight tooth and nail they
hire lobbyists after lawyer after
politician to make sure that the minimum
wage stays exactly where it is as these
large corporations grow exponentially
inside based off of the labor of the
people that they refuse to pay a living
wage you are never going to find empathy
out of those people
[Music]
uh so there it is and that's why over
the last uh this week I have not had an
ounce not a smidge yeah
um of empathy or Sympathy for the people
inside that craft or the people who came
before them because apparently there was
there was people who survived this thing
yeah and they're like holy [__] yeah
maybe you should wake up maybe what you
should do is now go and and figure out
why you are still alive and what you
should do with your wealth other than
stupid things like go to the bottom of
the ocean in a beer can with some dumb
idiot some wish.com Elon Musk yeah maybe
you should reevaluate things and use
your money for better ways and better
things uh so thanks for Justin for
finding that that video and showing it
to us because look we're not we're not
exactly
um laughing at these people we just
don't have sympathy or empathy for you
anymore yeah we just don't especially
when if the tables were turned you
wouldn't have you know they wouldn't
have any of that same type of empathy or
sympathy to the situation if we were
lost right I mean look at how they
handle refugees they're like oh [__]
that's well there is there is a story
there is a story about a sea craft
sinking with a bunch of migrants on it
yeah poor migrants hundreds of them hmm
and you know what's you know what's
funny about that story is there's a
um the boat that came to a rescue was
not the United States Navy it wasn't the
French Navy or the Canadian Navy or any
Navy in for that matter did you know
that it was a [__] yacht it was a
yacht of a rich and I believe I believe
they're a rich Mexican family there's a
yacht of a rich Mexican family that was
within the shot of this SOS from this
ship and they went and they got hundreds
hundreds of these migrants onto their
ship uh to save them and to you know
save them from drowning in the see with
their lifeboats and that sort of thing
and was in the Navy it wasn't there was
there's not a big headline about it
there's not people talking about it or
trying to distract people that the
hunter Biden plea actually perused and
Hunter Biden and guilty of the crimes
that the GOP wants to lie and accuse him
of right there's not actual
whistleblowers it's all [__] they're
paid actors they're paid crisis actors
that's what the GOP always says that
these people are and they're projecting
it's the same thing speaking of
Crisis actors
the Supreme Court there's a few of them
on there right
Alito is one of them uh Clarence Thomas
is one of them I believe the reason why
Supreme Court was on the bone of the
week is because of a lot of this dirty
money that it seems that these justices
are being bought and paid for by either
Harlan Hitler or some [__] obscure
Alaskan billionaire that they want to
make sure that they get the decisions
that they want in the court but I will
say is bone-ended as a court is this
morning did you hear the news of the 8-1
decision in the immigration policy
did you hear this no I didn't this is
not a boneheaded moment in the Supreme
Court I believe though that the reason
why even the the um button paid for
Supreme Court Justices
um and you know them all too well the
right Wingers the Nazis on the court
um the reason why they voted in favor of
this to make sure that the
Administration has the ability to set
immigration policy because they're the
federal government uh Texas actually is
the one who brought this lawsuit
um against the administration saying
that you cannot do what we don't want
you to do whatever in the moment it is
that we don't want you to do because
that's basically what this is
and because it's frivolous and the
Supreme Court in an eight to one
decision told the state of Texas you do
not have standing because it's not your
border it's the national border not your
border and not only can you not tell the
government what they can and can't do as
long as they're doing something to
implement the policies you stay the [__]
out of it
um in an eight to one decision which
basically gives the the Biden
Administration and any Administration
now be clear on this
um any Administration whether it be
Biden Administration or another fascist
regime like a DeSantis regime or a trump
regime where they would Implement their
shitty ass policies on the border right
but the Supreme Court did decide this
morning that the Administration has the
ability to set their policies and
implement the policies the way that they
deem necessary
um and this is some Stu this is another
stupid [__] line from the GOP which
we have on our bonehead list too which
if you haven't figured out by now
they're the winner but there's a lot of
reasons why the GOP is the winner and
they came out strong in one big but
first I want to go to the alpha cook
because what is the reason why this guy
is Alpha guck this week Elon Musk Elon
Musk has been Alpha cut several times
hasn't he yeah yeah but he's the alpha
cook because uh I was thinking about
doing RFK Jr but the reason I put Elon
Musk on there ahead of RFK yeah yeah
it's because Elon Musk is the one that's
platforming RFK Jr well everyone keeps
saying that everyone keeps saying RFK
junior is so popular look everyone's
tweeting about him like yeah because
he's a [__] nut job yeah he's crazy
why he's trending is because he's a
[__] idiot discern the tweets that
say he's [__] nuts and right he's
[__] great like I can I can assume
that there is a majority of people that
think he's [__] nuts versus he's
[__] smart or sane or he's doing a
lot of sense like all of the people who
think that RFK Jr is the you know next
to [__] Trump are Trump supporters
right you got Tim Poole and that Luke
other guy they're all trying to create
this
we like Democrats because we like RFK Jr
right right get out of here so the and
so I come after I come after Elon Musk
and I put him as Alpha cook because he
used his platform
to not engage directly like he had some
comments some responses here and there
but his activity of platforming Joe
Rogan and saying that Dr Hotes who is a
well-respected scientist who's literally
worked on the covet vaccine and created
a low-cost effect efficient vaccine in
areas like India right that would combat
and the reason that [__] big Pharma
wasn't able to get into India is because
of him right so that would totally go
against the narrative that like part of
a big Pharma shill would go against that
it would go for this we need small
government and we need this we don't
want big Pharma that's exactly what
conservatives claim they want right and
so you have Elon Musk who is cooking and
saying like oh well I'm just going to
ask these questions he seems a little
bit too afraid this and this and that
blah blah blah blah blah then he attacks
uh continues to attack the trans
community and then most recently yeah he
said CIS and cisgender are now dirty or
like uh they're slayers slurs on Twitter
don't call me sister sis Ginger it hurts
my feelings and that's against my
freedom of speech because I don't want
to hear it so it's not for him a speech
because I'm weak and I'm a snowflake and
I'm a little [__] and I don't want to
hear what you have to say because it
hurts my feelings that's what he is I
think that's the quote actually yeah
yeah it's almost a direct quote verbatim
I mean we also have to remember that
that Elon Musk his own child
went to the LA court and was like look I
not only want to change my [__] name
because my father won't respect that I'm
trans
and then also was like I don't want
anything to do
ah Jezebel 11 here on YouTube says [__]
fit
it's a [__] fit that's hilarious please
don't please don't make a meme with that
on it somebody it just goes to show you
that Elon Musk he's a little [__] ass
[__] and he's a cuck and he's upset
that uh that trans people have rights
and they're respected as humans and then
not only that but that there are actual
you know science and data to prove that
vaccines work and that Dr Hotes doesn't
have to go on a [__] podcast with an
MMA fighter slash failed comedian to say
oh you should debate this dude debate me
bro debate me bro or like I guess the
way that RFK Junior sounds
are you making fun of his voice please I
mean I'm just saying I'm not making fun
of it I'm just trying to do inaccurate
representation yeah right for the quote
Teresa here on YouTube says thank you
for calling uh RFK what he is a [__]
nut and plus two now here's here's what
I'll show you about RFK do you want to
know the truth about it do you want to
treat the batteries
I've been saying it for a long time the
VEC and RFK are in this race for Trump
and that's the only reason why they're
in the races to help Trump and it is it
is overt it is not covert it is overt
they're saying [__] out loud that helps
Trump let me show you the evidence and I
don't need any more evidence that just
tell me Vivek and RFK are running to
help Trump without telling me that
they're running to help Trump Laura
Loomer says this Laura Loomer tweets
this just like she tweeted she thinks
Carrie lake is hot
yeah
sorry I I will throw up in my mouth
she says I like Trump I like the Vic I
like RFK this sounds like a really bad
Dr Seuss story doesn't it it's a it's
like the it's like a remedial kind of
poem and they're like okay just start
with things that you like right
then we'll go from there and we'll
figure out what kind of poem or
rhyming's style this is you know and
they're like okay we're just gonna very
basic
let me see if I can I like Trump I like
the thick and I like RFK is that pretty
close to her voice that's pretty goddamn
voice she says I can't stand the santis
okay if you're not paying attention to
what she's saying here she's saying I
don't want DeSantis to win the primary
and how to say if this is not going to
win the primary is what I just said
Trump Vivek and RFK that's our strategy
right because uh and Laura Loomer is not
officially part of the Trump campaign
because she's a nut job and they don't
want her as the official part of her
campaign she's begging them Gabe Sanchez
she's begging them on social media she
says at the very end and this is the
most important part of all this
narrative that is so important of why we
cannot lose sight of Avec RFK and Trump
and DeSantis in this race and these are
the wedges that we must drive she says
you couldn't pay me to ever vote for Ron
DeSantis ever again
fantastic Loomer fantastic you're doing
a wonderful job at
propagating ideas that will suppress
your vote great great job hang on to
this tweet screenshot this [__]
we may need it the point here is is that
babek and RFK are in this race to help
Trump and hurt DeSantis they don't want
DeSantis to be the nominee and the
reason why is because if DeSantis is a
nominee Trump will go to prison his only
way out of this the only way out of this
is for him to be the nominee because
that will give him the chance to be the
president United States that's his only
way out of this that's it there's no
other way
and that's why they're saying this this
[__] so this gives you the example
of why RFK now I know that's a long way
around from our bonehead of the week
here Elon Musk but Elon Musk is
platforming RFK and the reason why he's
platforming RFK I believe is because he
wants Trump back on Twitter so yeah he
knows if he can get RFK and platform RFK
in Trump's favor Trump might come back
to Twitter yep and that's what I think
he's trying I mean he's desperate right
he needs engagement but here's the thing
just because Elon Musk and and this is
how short-sighted and simple-minded Elon
Musk is Elon Musk thinks oh if I have
more people here and I have more
engagement regardless if it's good or
bad engagement I'm gonna make more money
uh nope that's not how it works uh the
way that you make money
is you have advertisers who feel
confident to put their brand on your
platform right that they're willing to
pay you to Target a demographic so that
those people then click that ad and then
purchase that product or subscribe to
that service
but if not a lot of people come back
then you have a what oh oh a diminishing
uh Revenue stream and you can't pay for
the goddamn interest on your 13 billion
dollar loan okay 1.5 or whatever is owed
this year
he's gonna owe another set next year and
another and another another right or
like I think maybe it could even be like
biannual
but
Elon Musk is a [__] idiot and he
thinks that by driving Donald Trump to
the platform and driving other people
who are conspiracy theorists and
anti-vaxxers and Maga and Jan Sixers and
Q Anon people he's thinking oh yeah if I
drive up that engagement it will turn
into a successful product and you can
have a bunch of people I mean look at
[__] get her look at [__] Clapper
look at [__] parlor look at gab like
well gab I don't know how they were
doing but the other three have done
incredibly shitty because a bunch of
crazy people yelling at the top of their
lungs about things that aren't actually
real right they're talking about gay
frogs and queer beer and they're talking
about the election was stolen dude move
on man it's been [__] three years bro
right right [__] over it right dude do
you want do you do you news bro
news dude dude good Lord good Lord
speaking speaking of people who don't
news the winner this week the GOP the
Geo
is the winner this week they definitely
do not news over at the GOP they don't
have the facts they don't listen to
anything that's the truth it is their
their Moto operandi Moto zapper and I
know you know what the greatest part is
is that
um Lauren bobert and Marjorie Taylor
green the face of the GOP had a little
spat on the house floor right yeah and
well they called each other a little
[__] or something they came out and
talked about it too right and uh this
week they really stepped on a lot of
rakes the GOP stepped on a lot of rakes
um that a lot of rakes they're saying
that the best rakes ever the huge huge
rakes
in particular the one that Donald Trump
stepped on was to go on a two-part
interview on Fox News again they're part
of our bonehead of the week as well it's
kind of it all intersects it's an
interweb of stupidity and both did in
this I'm sorry it just is
um but Donald Trump really um their
leader of the GOP which he clearly is
that's why they had decenture Adam ship
and why they brought some some articles
of impeachment which will go absolutely
nowhere I don't know if they know this
to impeach a president they have to have
them
what's that thing called that Jack Smith
has what is this oh oh yeah that's right
evidence that thing that Jack Smith has
on Donald Trump speaking of that here is
their dear leader the guy who who
ordered them the center Adams shift and
to impeach Joe Biden for God knows what
here he is talking about his legal owes
down at Mar-A-Lago if this doesn't
explain why the GOP is the bonehead of
the week I don't know what else does but
here you go you know I tell all these
people they all come in they want to
help and the biggest people some of the
biggest people the biggest law firms the
biggest lawyers
okay so what he said was what he said
was I'm charged with 37. listen to this
37 felony counts of breaking the
Espionage Act it's clear that the
evidence in this is very very very
damning evidence because when the
discovery was dropped on the defense the
other day he lost his [__] mind and
was begging Congress he was begging
Congress to help him but Gabe Sanchez
we're supposed to believe
and when the best brightest biggest I
don't know if they're like nine foot
tall or something is there like a
lawyers out there that are like nine
foot yeah cause he said the best
Moonlight they Moonlight as lawyers but
they're actually the starting five for a
team oh in the NBA I see maybe the
Washington generals
that Matt gatz referred to the other day
in the Durham hearing
he's saying he's begging for help for
Congress to help him in these
investigations but he doesn't need
lawyers to do it now what this tells you
more than anything is that Donald
Trump's plan is not
not to undo this investigation in the
courts his plan is to undo it with
Congress and him being president yeah I
I'm telling you that's what he's telling
you out loud and the GOP can't do
anything they can't they can't
they can't even figure out how to make
sure Health Care is Affordable and you
don't go broke because of a medical bill
they can't figure out how children
should probably start education at three
instead of five so they can start early
and parents don't have to pay daycare
they can't figure out why the social
safety nets are so important so crucial
to our economy they can't figure out why
migrants are so crucial migrant workers
are so crucial to our economy uh I.E
Rhonda santis in Florida they can't
figure out how Joe Biden has managed to
decrease inflation all the while
plummeting unemployment in this country
and why the economy is so great even
though prices still remain higher than
they have been they still can't figure
that out they can't figure out how many
so many Americans became wealthy beyond
their Wildest Dreams because of real
estate inflation in this country they
can't figure that out they can't figure
out why the stock market's so high they
cannot figure out all these problems and
there's nothing they'll do about it
climate change all the way down to
Medicare and Medicaid okay and the
reason why is because they can't focus
on anything but this [__] their
orange Mussolini Jesus and the reason
why the [__] on the phone with
them constantly every day saying hey you
got to protect me you got to protect me
God damn I can't find a lawyer I can't
even get a lawyer that will even give me
a [__] return phone call you have to
protect me he's saying it out loud folks
and this is why the GOP sucks is because
they're following his lead and I keep
telling him this over and over whether
you believe me or not Donald Trump is
going to be their nominee he just is and
if you don't know why I'll give you
another example this is apparently a
Jerry Springer episode even though he's
passed from last week where Lauren
bobert marger Taylor green appeared on
it what no this is real this is totally
real this is totally not Photoshop it
looks very real
um when you have these two hold on keep
talking I'm gonna this is the topic I
need to go get something real quick yeah
okay yeah this is the reason why that
the GOP is on the bonehead of the week
this week is because we are supposed to
take Serious that these two people are
fighting over who's gonna impeach Biden
first for the Fox news clip
then the actual impeachment itself folks
if they had evidence of any of this of
any of this the United States Attorney
that Donald Trump appointed in Delaware
would have made sure that they smoked
out any bribery payments any of them
rather you post fake text messages of
Hunter Biden on the Internet or not
because they're doing that this morning
they they have gotten so [__]
infuriated that there's their story of
Hunter Biden and all his crimes has been
smashed up in one Fell Swoop of Hunter
Biden taking a plea deal on two
misdemeanor counts of uh of a tax
evasion and one felony count of a gun
charge which is a stupid gun charge and
the 2A bro should be super mad super mad
big mad about that gun charge but
they're not
is that their entire Narrative of Hunter
Biden has been smashed up that one Fell
Swoop they're willing to create fake
test text messages of Hunter Biden
saying yeah yeah Joe Biden was in the
room when these bribes happen listen
folks a fake text message a screenshot
of a fake text message from Hunter Biden
to God knows who about Hunter Biden
saying that Joe Biden's in the room when
they're demanding a Chinese bribe is not
evidence
is not evidence and the reason why it's
not is because the United States
Attorney in Delaware did not have that
evidence because it doesn't exist until
this morning on social media or whenever
they posted these fake text messages
it's all [__] it's all nonsense it's
all lies it's all gaslighting it has
been for years from the GOP
it's the reason why they had to save gas
stoves last week and they had Accenture
and impeach Adam Schiff and Joe Biden
this week because it's always the scary
Boogeyman that they have a whistleblower
for and they have evidence for but they
can't show you because if they show you
then you'll know and if you know then
you'll know the truth which is that it's
all 100 [__] [__] the entirety of
it all of it including this picture it's
complete [__] but it looks accurate
to me what do you think Gabe Sanchez it
looks pretty close I actually just
posted a video
uh hold on let me go find it let me go
find it on on Twitter on on Twitter okay
once is this a video of uh
of these two twits
yeah
this is I just I just did it for
everyone watching I made this video last
night I showed Tony a rough cut oh yeah
yeah I had to make a slight change uh
that I was working on okay well let me
let me so this is um this is actually
this is actual footage of Mars actually
the dream yeah this is uh footage of
Marjorie Taylor green after Lauren
bobert copied her article's impeachment
against President Trump and this is
going to explain why they're on the bone
of the week so let's watch this footage
this is uh this is exclusive footage to
the Tony Michaels podcast right now
watch
laughs
Jesus Christ
this girl is the
nastiest
[Laughter]
she is a ugly
I can't guess what's gonna happen
[Music]
oh my God
so there you go we are definitely we are
definitely gonna get dinged on that no
I'm almost I'm almost 100 certain that
we're going to get well it doesn't
matter it's real footage though right
it's real footage yeah yeah we'll just
challenge the cops somebody might say
it's a copyright claim but uh well I was
again just like that photo of Carrie
Lake and Donald Trump
him kissing her
I'm just saying this is real footage
that
um well if we do get a copyright ding
I'm gonna challenge it for 100 actually
you know what let me check something
um yeah let's see no man we actually did
not get a copyright ding I am very
surprised for
um possibly playing Under the Sea we may
have done that I'm not saying we did so
if you're listening out there YouTube we
may or may not have so don't please
don't pay attention to this part of the
show
um but we did not get a copyright name
for that and then there was something
yesterday that we played that I thought
we was going to get a copyright ding on
but I don't think we did on that one
either so maybe they'll just they're
they're they're giving us passes yeah on
this uh for now are are they all either
that or they're all coming at once
because I would imagine that under the
sea I was I was telling my son yesterday
because we were talking about this uh
Titanic thing and I told him we played
the under the sea because I played the
video for me thought it was hilarious
yeah and then
and I said the probably the reason why
Disney hasn't given me a copyright
strike yet is because there's so many
copyright strikes that they're working
on right now for the song Under the Sea
like they're they're just overloaded to
[__] go out and find the these these
copyrights since this thing but that I'm
telling you this footage here the Gabe
Sanchez has that's right footage man
it's real footage it's definitely will
challenge the copyright claim if it
comes in
as soon as that happened as soon as I
heard about what was going on I was like
oh my God
well this is exactly this moment I I
tell you I I can't tell you how excited
I am about a um
a bikini oil match between Elon and
Zuckerberg yeah yeah
I think that's what it is right isn't
that what they're gonna do without yeah
they're gonna octagon Las Vegas they're
gonna oil up and they're gonna right
they're gonna put because they're gonna
Peterson that's what he said when he
came back five hours later right and
then said oh I hope it's olive oil it's
like bro how long have you been thinking
about this dude he's a little right it's
like if that's Jordan dude man that's
totally cool Jordan if you want to come
on the show this this we are allies here
we are allies here and we respect the
lgbtq community and their choices and
their Liberty and their freedom to be
that way and if you want to come on the
show and tell us anything that you want
to tell us about that
um of your own personal experience and
maybe a closet that you have kind of
like Gabe's got behind him if you got
skeletons come on the show we're we're
allies man come on the show Jordan come
on the show man come on the show just
like just like I would encourage
Marjorie Taylor green and Lauren bober
to come on the show to Hash this out
this little [__] yeah
come on come after me for that video
yeah let's do it let's do it yeah
this is why the GOP is the bone end of
the week because they can't stop being
boneheads oh my God they're they're the
party of boneheads so let's give them
their do
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah GOP is the bonehead of the week
I mean there's so many things we could
play between Kevin McCarthy just being
totally [__] cucked on the house
floor by his Maga members and them being
booed and heckled by the Democratic
members because he just he's forced to
do these stupid things uh in
in in genuflect to Donald Trump it's
[__] disgusting
um and the GOP cannot get out of their
way and to actually have Ron DeSantis
throw some real [__] punches at
Donald Trump he continues to have to get
him on covet and lockdowns when there's
clear obvious things that he could be
debating him on and telling the country
do you really want a [__] criminal
who's who's [__] indicted on over 70
felony counts probably going to be
double or triple that oh he'll get to
Hillary he'll have triple digits I think
by these years
we've got uh right we still got Fulton
County right we still have
um Jan six right right
there's another here's another GOP thing
that I want to Caitlyn shows here about
the um the the
um the parent Brigade are the moms of
Liberty uh quoting Hitler on their
newsletter which is a real thing they
did quote Hitler on the newsletter but I
found this
um and you shouldn't circulate this
around because this is real
this may or may not been posted on our
our pod account this morning
um it is a statement from the parent
Brigade over the moms of Liberty oh wow
it's 100 real Hondo
Hondo this is definitely not parody even
though it has a watermark here saying it
um it definitely is not
um it says we're totally sorry that we
got caught saying the quiet part out
loud about Hitler
um when we put his quote on our
newsletter because we love Hitler and
we're obviously uh an arm of The Proud
boys who are fascists and who are Nazis
and we are Nazis we're the moms of
Liberty we're Nazis okay that doesn't
actually say that but it says we're
totally sorry that we got saying the
quiet part out loud if you let us pick
your history books we wouldn't be in
this mess now okay it's your fault
it kind of sounds like the apology that
they that they put out yeah yeah yeah I
mean I just did from Paige Miller moms
of Liberty I mean it seems legit to me
you know it does uh to me yeah if I was
gonna make a statement or read a
statement from a from a group that seems
pretty legit to me man I think it I
think it seems legit uh for you who
don't know
um and again that statement is out there
on the internet now and it's definitely
real it's not parody even though there's
a watermark saying it yeah um here is
this this image here let me see if I can
find it the image of the newsletter that
was sent out by the moms of Liberty did
you know that Mom's a liberty are gonna
have a big National Convention and um
Rhonda Santos is going to speak at it no
yeah but I also heard another another
person with the r in their name yeah
um RFK is gonna be junior yeah Junior
yes well maybe RFK who knows JFK Jr come
back alive maybe RFK there's a lot
there's a lot of people that are coming
back alive these days no any age and
speaking of huge the huge orange deity
is going to be there as well
um at the uh mom's delivery National
Convention but let me show you well let
me show you the July 20 2023 Hamilton
County chapters newsletter here from
moms of Liberty if you didn't know
um this is they're quoting here a famous
historical figure
God this is [__] real
and they literally put it on the front
of the newsletter and it says with hot
in highlights they've highlighted it
it's not even like tried to hide the
[__] very top
in a highlighted box now this this has a
red circle around it so you can see it
that wasn't originally there but this is
just to point it out it says he alone
who owns the youth gains the future
quoting Adolf Hitler you know what you
know what's crazy about this there was a
woman at January 6 okay that was
standing on stage speaking in front of
the Capitol at that time that is what
she was she did this quote for Madoff
Hitler did you really yeah yeah he alone
he owns the youth gains the future
they were talking a minute and I think
she did they say
she said she said Adolf Hitler wasn't
right on a few things but he's
definitely right on this
look he wasn't right about that but uh
right he's definitely look look we gotta
find the bright spots
one thing right doesn't mean that I
think he's right about everything you
know look he definitely he definitely
was right about a lot right I mean come
on and we definitely want to point that
out huh he was right or white well I
mean you know he was he was white about
everything they think white is right so
yeah yeah right so I mean right who's
who's counting here
um but yes this is uh the the moms of
Liberty Hamilton County and again this
is an arm of the GOP if you don't
believe me this is an arm of gwp all the
gopiers are gonna go to their National
Convention and speak in support of them
and support of them they love them they
can't wait for moms of Liberty to be
their ground game in their in their
fight for white Christian nationalism to
be instituted inside our governments
and fascism including the way that they
love Adolf Hitler and his quote here he
alone who owns the youth gains the
future you [__] scumbags I'm glad I'm
glad that was brought to my attention
Hitler Youth uh 2024 right well yeah
well Yoo-hoo yay oh my God
the GOP bone end of the week winners you
know what stick around we got a few
announcements and I got a few more
things I want to show you before the
weekend because yeah we're overtime
anyways so why the hell out stick around
anywhere we'll be right back right after
music to show you a few more things make
you laugh a little more into the weekend
bonetta though week
[Music]
[Applause]
oh bonehead of the week
again I want to show you this this is
important
we were talking about the cisgender
thing how Elon Musk is really scared of
the word sis
don't say it on Twitter this is a free
speech platform you're not allowed to
Camp that in
come on man get the [__] out of here he
actually said that [__] but here here's
here let me give you a graphic to
explain this to the people out there
of why you think CIS is a slur let me
explain to you cisgender people think
CIS is a slur because they think trans
is a slur see see how that works see see
you oh no no not not think they use
trains yeah that's right they use it as
a slur oh you're trans yeah and they
think yeah that actually makes a lot of
sense that's why that's uh that's why
that's why Elon is confused man these
people are so [__] shitty well here's
here is uh Charlie Kirk's take on it oh
you think Elon Musk is take wait till
you see faceplates take ah it's [__]
great he said she is a slur I'm such a
[__] [__] well you didn't say that
but yeah that's the connotation here
quote sex assigned at Birth is a logical
fallacy gender affirming cares child
mutilation what if it's done on I don't
know someone like Elon Musk is wanting
hair plugs right is that child
mutilation Charlie Charlie face
reconstructed so you're [__] your
face structure is proper right what
about yourself right no I know that's
Stephen even Crowder well that's true
I'm just is that gender affirming is
that child these are all gender
affirming right uh
surgeries that you do on your body right
minor attracted persons are pedophiles
what the [__] does that mean
what does that mean well how do they
even come up with this [__] dude if
you're thinking this deep into
pedophilia um someone better check
Charlie's browser history that's all I'm
saying man I mean are we going to look
at the Republican Party are we gonna
look at how when it comes to their
projection it's really uh you know it
tends to be nine times ten times out of
ten in admission of guilt it's a
confession
when you oh look oh this person was uh
was charged with uh having child
pornography on their computer this
person was charged with having you know
sex trafficking time and time again time
and time again with the projection
speaking in projection his next
statement trans is a mental delusion
holy [__] man you're transphobian
homophobia is more of a mental delusion
than you could ever dream of my friend
and then he says this is this is great
oh my god you dumb [__] reclaim
the language they stole from us
what do you think sis is man it's
language what are you talking about
what did we steal from them I don't know
the the word sis has been around since
the turn of the [__] century and
really it was I just don't it was made
famous by someone who was persecuted by
Nazis it's the first transgender Clinic
it's the idea that they you know they
continue to play victim them and say oh
no no no no we're not the ones we're not
attacking them we're just retaliating
because they took something from us yeah
they stole our language right I mean
let's not talk about white people and
how they steal people's culture right oh
oh don't even get Charlie started I mean
if there's anyone that that you know
would like to appropriate things it's
definitely Charlie Kirk if you look at
Charlie Kirk he is the most vanilla
plain boring person out there [__] me
lies on other what
I knew I retweeted that [__] oh you've
been looked forever and I [__]
retweeted that [__] two days ago God
damn it it was literally Carrie Lake's
War Room tweeted this [__] with that
blow up doll God damn it
that's why I thought and it I mean and
they tweeted this there's only one man
who can keep our country afloat well I
mean there's a thing I look at this and
I see uh
it's it's keeping it afloat I don't know
but also it could be like there's only
one man I want to have wrapped around me
Donald Trump yeah I do like how the uh
the blow up doll here accentuates the
size of his hands like again proportion
wise
it's way off way off way too big I mean
we need we need you know hands small
hands tiny hands powerful hands powerful
hands
what what's that chop thing that you do
one thing
my voice morning uh
what's up
I just wanted to leave the audience with
the Cheeto chop
um before the weekend this weekend is
gonna be
the most magnificent weekend even
get cheetah fingers cheetah chap one
more thing I want to show you before we
go yeah um if you really want to rub the
gop's nose and some [__] [__] this
weekend look at this this is a picture
of I-95
um the one that collapsed yeah here it
is now this is um during the
construction of trying to get it back
open did you know did you know that
thing collapsed right and you made a
meme about I think we showed it on here
um but the crazy thing about it is that
the governor of Pennsylvania Josh
Imperial a Democrat and the Democratic
Secretary of Transportation because I 95
is such a uh an important Corridor there
um Pennsylvania
they wanted to get it back open as fast
as they could the crazy part the crazy
part is they use new technology
um and they used the efforts of uh
government which is kind of funny here
that they use the efforts of government
uh to end the unions did you know this
they use the efforts of the Union Zoo oh
man
um so it's so it's not only Democrats
the government and the unions the
trifecta that really proves that the GOP
are dumb [__] oh look here look
here look at that [__] it's open and I
think it's running right now because I
think it was supposed to be noon noon
today is when they were gonna get that's
crazy that's so fast 13 [__] days I
got that thing open
did you know this did you know this no
yeah absolutely it's crazy that's
[__] real that's how they finished
the middle part so here's they're gonna
finish yeah so here's what they did huh
um I was reading about this this morning
apparently you see crazy right you see
this well in technology crazy too you
see this uh it looks like it's almost
like a wall down below here right yeah
apparently this is compact glass right
and it's this new technology where
because they can stack them easy very
fast and then build a roadway over top
of it so what they did is they built a
roadway so they can run three lanes at a
time which I-95 I believe is five or six
Lanes of traffic yeah it looks like it's
normal it looks like five maybe that's a
shoulder right there yeah I can't I
don't know I've never been on I-95 there
um but but it's either five or six Lanes
I believe but they're getting it down
the three lanes on each side which is
still gonna bottleneck step but it's
still going to open up this Fairway yeah
it's not a [__] Gap right right so so
now so now so now this major artery is
open within 13 days thanks to Democrats
thanks to uh unions and thanks to uh I
know I don't know um technology and yeah
yeah yeah I mean could you say that
there was money coming from a bill
that's for infrastructure that was maybe
passed while the certain President Joe
Biden was in
you know it's kind of funny too this
week when this happened or last week
when this happened and and into this
week when this happened the GOP did
nothing did nothing in the house to try
to appropriate funds to get this I-95
back going so what the administration
did is they just took matters in their
own hands and they get that got this
back open as fast as they possibly could
which they didn't in less than 13 days
which is crazy that they were able to do
this now I want to point out um if you
look at this picture what they're going
to do is they're going to actually build
the permanent roadway on either side of
this and then they'll actually tear this
one down and run the three lanes on each
side and then they'll rebuild the middle
rebuilding the entire Road getting it
back up and ready to yeah permanently as
opposed to this temporary fix where they
can open eyes crazy so in that nuts in
that nuts what government and and just
like actual serious people who are
interested and I don't know helping
folks out fix the problems that come
their way rather it's hell Healthcare or
daycare education or I I don't know
maybe you're a road [__] collapses in
a major [__] Interstate collapses and
government swoops in and says hey you
know what instead of instead of bakely
saving gas stoves and making up [__]
about 100 by and Joe bite maybe what we
should do is I don't know fix this
little spot 995. it would do that I mean
it would do that it would make sense
right The Logical reasonable thing to do
to go forward with this would be oh look
we don't need to have this fake outrage
if we're going to project our outrage
let's go towards this thing
yeah we have a problem let's provide a
solution but if you have a problem yo
I'll solve it check out the hook when
the DJ revolves it nice eyes baby
so Wu Tang for is for children uh
tweeted this they said wow less than two
weeks they got it done thank you Biden
government Shapiro Governor Shapiro
secretary Buddha judge and most
important union workers so very
impressive very interesting [__]
impressive Tony I gotta tell you I gotta
go do you gotta go all right all right
go ahead and bounce out because of this
comment well okay let's see I'm leaving
when is it you have to lose Gabe I'm
sorry he's adorable the support and
Spins with City he's boring I'm sorry
um so you know I'm sorry I'm sorry I
gotta you are boring
[__] that [__]
goofing on these [__] idiots
I wanted to bring up because I thought
it was funny oh yeah uh anyway you're
right I had fun we're we're closing in
on on three hours yeah
I didn't know that you didn't see that
story about the uh I-95 no I know I mean
the last I the last I heard uh was when
it collapsed well I know you made the
meme right right and Ted Cruz and yeah
but uh but yeah no they get there they
got now it's not permanent yet it's just
a temporary piece I didn't know that
technology existed that they use glass
well yeah you were gonna say that they
were going to continues in glass because
it was absorbed like absorbing in in
yeah it's just it's a it's a block uh
it's blocks of compressed glass they use
it to recycle compressed glass yeah and
they're using it all around the country
so that's cool I didn't know that that
people were using uh recycled glass that
way well I mean they're trying to
re-engineer
um a lot out of this stuff to build the
same things you need to build an
infrastructure with less material and
the reason why is because [__]
material is expensive whether it's
asphalt concrete whatever it's more
expensive uh steel so they're trying to
use less of it and get the same results
in the engineering which may or may not
be a good thing
depends on you know who's doing the
engineering whether it's the guy with
the last name rush or it's actual people
who know
what the [__] they're doing I mean
that's important that's important
um let me see if I've got I thought I
had one more thing I wanted to show here
maybe I'm that I missed this week no no
you got six minutes what are you gonna
do yeah well you know
cut it at 11 59.
do you gotta go do you get do you know I
don't have to go I mean we should cut it
off at three hours obviously I got it
but according to one person I'm very
boring so I have to go well you know
that happens oh here's the thing we
missed speaking of Ocean Gate
um have you seen the stepson of the guy
the CEO yeah yeah I've seen it oh my God
this is [__] hilarious can can you
can you pull up a couple videos why I
pull up this one thing so this is one
thing that uh that the internet pointed
out that Twitter pointed out
um early on now this is when they still
thought there was a chance these people
still be alive this the stepson of this
billionaire
um he was like oh thanks for the
thoughts and prayers I'm so glad and
then he was doing this on social media
so the steps on a missing billionaire on
Titanic's um submarine shoots his shot
with his only fans model as Rescuers
scramble the locators rather this is
real this is a real screenshot from
Twitter here
um his name is Brian he's an audio guy
oh my God audio guy 182 apparently likes
blink 182.
she posts this this isn't only fans
model you see a lot of this on Twitter
now like they're pushing this in the
algorithm like crazy or it's just
because it's my page and I've seen a lot
probably it could be it could be the
algorithm that knows who I am and it's
possible
um Breer says can you can I sit on you I
mean that's a I mean you know it's a
reasonable question I guess for someone
who's an only Van's model who's trying
to Market her it's sex listen sex work
is work people I believe in that I think
Marie has the absolute right to sell
images of her body she she can profit
out the image of her body and she can
even lure dummies in like Brian here to
give her money for that here's what he
said
so he says yes please right an hour
before that he was like please keep my
family in your prayers
he's like please keep my family and your
prayers for my billionaire dad which
probably has gazillions of dollars worth
of life insurance that I'm going to
benefit off of as soon as he's dead and
oh yeah I really want her to sit on my
face that's right that's this is the guy
and we're supposed to feel sorry for
these people come yeah I mean I'm trying
to find a video where he sings blink
182. is that what it is well this he's
he's had go to go cardi B search cardi B
he apparently cardi B said something to
him uh responded to this step step oh is
that the one where I saw a video where
there's like a muscle character that's
hugging her yeah I know and she's like
you gotta stop dude oh yeah yeah here we
go and then he he he filmed the response
to her I haven't actually watched it but
I'm sure it's all right so here's here's
the one is this the cardi B he's the
cardi B one and I think it's
[__] weird man dude and a lot of
people haven't dug this deep into the
ocean uh gate
um controversy but this is this this is
the this is the video is this this is
the video of her right this is the video
of cardi B okay let's watch this okay so
one of the billionaires that's missing
on the on the water from that submarine
[__]
one of the billionaires their stepson is
at a concert right at Blink 182 concert
and people is like
um well what is he supposed to do be sad
at the house is he supposed to go look
for himself yes you're supposed to be at
the house sad you're supposed to be
crying for me you're supposed to be
right next to the phone waiting to hear
any updates about me you're supposed to
be uh constantly your mom and she isn't
it sad that you a whole billionaire and
nobody what what the [__] is this filter
what the [__] she does this from time
to time where there's a filter that you
can do on on like Instagram this is
[__] there's different characters
that you can put in there and I hadn't
seen this one this is like one of those
like um there's like Body Works have you
ever been to like the like Natural
Museum of Science right
um this is that's what this reminds me
of it reminds me of like some sort of
promotion for the Bodyworks display
which is like real right bodies that
have been donated like just the skin
took off something to see yeah I'll tell
you I'll tell you about cardi B I follow
her on Instagram the best video she does
on Instagram because she has those long
nails is when she's cooking oh yeah
[__] hilarious because she's like
trying to pick it up and she can't pick
it up so they have to cut and someone
has to hand it to her yeah
it's those are some of the best [__]
videos that cardi B does like that's
Artistry when she's trying to cook with
those Nails okay so this is a response
to that video yeah so this is the
response that he had this is the
response from the the actual stepson of
the billionaire that
um is at the bottom well what is left of
him at the bottom of the ocean and this
is his response to cardi B uh here
let's listen to this guy I'm sure he's
not an idiot surely he's not an idiot
right okay let's see
so you take a complete [__] like cardi
B has no idea what's going on her career
is so in such turmoil she needs clout
off other people's suffering
wait wait a cardi B needs clout from
this guy yeah but also from someone
else's suffering this guy was he's like
where are they Danny he's over here I
gotta find the video but he's singing
[__] blink 182. he's asking only fans
models to sit on his face while he's
asking for Thought which I'm not against
man I'm telling you if I had a tragedy
in my life I mean if it was a tragic
moment in my life and then only fans
models like hey you want me to sit on
your face or help out I'd be like well
am I you know I I could see how that
would help a guy out but this that he's
he's saying cardi B is using him for
clout who who the [__] is this guy let's
keep listening and she's like hey he
won't go hell
he goes to a rock concert listen that
tries to use the situation to exploit
like the news they're not like feeling
sorry that my mom has to take care of
two kids not really giving a [__] that
my stepdad's probably 99 chance he's
dead that doesn't matter doesn't care
how we feel just he he doesn't seem to
care if his dad's and stepdad's 99 yeah
he also said in another video he was
like I've got a hundred dollars to my
name
this guy yeah what that's what he's the
[__] out of here he's uh I I don't know
if people heard this he's the
Billionaire's stepson I doubt I mean he
may have a hundred dollars to his name
but I doubt the stepdad only had a
hundred dollars to his name oh yeah no
no no no just trying to like [__]
make gains people like um crawling
getting hate mail all these things and
it's just
[__] up and have cardi B behind it
cardi B like [__] grow up get some
class like you're tasteless
Pantene on what he was doing
because he went out and made comments
that were not okay uh and also made
comments that seemed insensitive right
at the time what was going on so
so the fact that she's kind of it's in
the public domain he did it he put it
out there right it wasn't unprompted by
cardi B she saw what he did and said
I'm going to comment and say that you
shouldn't be doing these things like if
you're going to be if you're gonna have
a class in any way like you shouldn't be
singing the songs or making jokes or
doing this or doing that and like don't
[__] shoot your shot for clout while
your dad is like most likely dead or
your stepdad's most likely dead but
still missing I I would almost bet that
if you dig in this guy's past he's
probably some kind of manga racist to
bigot and he's and the projection of him
saying oh don't clout Chase off me
okay as you clout Chase off cardi B and
your dad's death and the big story that
your dad's a dumb [__] and he paid 250
000 to get into again a beer can and to
only reach his ultimate demise as he
descended to the Bottom of the Sea yeah
okay and cardi B is the one yeah
actually here's and here's a little
context I think this is this was before
the cardi B
video okay I'm trying to remember or I'm
trying to figure out what what point in
response oh he's in the same dumb place
in the same dumb hat yeah okay let's
let's listen believe it or not I have
about a hundred dollars to my name
I can't go out to the ocean I have a
legal situation keeping me here as well
whoa whoa whoa someone needs to check
this guy's search history I don't know
what legal I have no idea I can't get on
a flight I don't have a passport
whoa whoa whoa you can't get on a flight
yeah it seems like it's a legal
situation that he's got a [__] like
what's this guy January 6th what's this
guy doing man I'm just saying like dude
the fact that he's like I got a legal
situation I can't get on it I don't know
how to passport flight list yeah but
he's on a no-fly list I don't get that
list or does he have to be he has to be
let's listen I was sitting here
yesterday watching the news for two days
straight I go to a Blink 182 shows they
have a ticket it wasn't like I was
having super fun it wasn't like well he
only's got 108 dollars because he bought
those expensive ass back in Blink-182 no
no no you can't be like oh here I was
for two days and then I decided to go to
a Blink 182 concert no he just never
have a ticket well yeah he had a ticket
but of course someone is going to come
after you if you're if your family
member was lost at sea
I don't know many people
unless they really don't care about the
person there's like some sociopath that
they would not
sit tight and like yeah you can't really
do anything in terms of like you know
fixing or improving the situation but
going to a concert feels like the last
thing you want to do I I want to stay on
this story um as much as we're over time
but real quick there I I I just got
pointed out here uh Scott McFarland has
some uh breaking news and this is
important in the January 6K since we
were kind of uh talking about it there
maybe this guy maybe the steps on this
January 6th defendant but this January
6th defendant
um new info awards host and Alex Jones
associate Jonathan uh Owen Shroyer uh
he's the guy that is on Infowars all the
time with Alex Jones he went to
um the capital January 6 has pled guilty
to January 6th case this is important
that he his plea uh because he's agreed
to cooperate with investigators
whoa baby whoa baby whoa baby I don't
know if you know this Gabe but Alex
Jones is uh Confidant of Roger Stone and
also Stuart Rhodes which you know that
for sure and also also on Donald Trump
I wonder I wonder I just wonder if
something's going on there so yeah and
we also know that there are the intimate
text messages
yeah between you know the Roger Stone
Alec Jones and and wife and we know and
we know that because Alex Jones
attorneys are dumb as [__] yeah and the
defamation case in Texas oh boy you
couldn't end on a better note with this
[__] stepson who is on the no fly
list yeah because of or whatever
reasonable reasons and he's clout
chasing on cardi B projecting his clout
chasing and then we end it with Alex
Jones's little co-host is cooperating
with the government in the January 6
case boy you can't get any better I bet
I know one person that's paying
attention
Jack Smith is paying attention to all
this and so are we here on the Johnny
Michaels podcast don't forget to
subscribe here on YouTube we will bring
this at you every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific
every single weekday I mean Friday
sometimes three hours but most of the
time two hours every single day don't
forget to follow us on Twitter at Tony
Michaels pod also you can watch us on
Facebook at the Tony Michaels you can
follow us for free on Twitch twitch.tv
don't mind because you can watch it over
there you can also
you can link your Amazon Prime account
to your Twitch account it gives us two
dollars every single month it's almost
enough to buy one of the the controllers
oh yeah that they use to for the beer
can we're gonna make our own Little
Submarine right right absolutely so keep
keep linking your Amazon Prime account
to your Twitch account maybe we'll make
our own little uh submarine submarine
one of these days with that Amazon money
also download every single episode on
Apple's Spotify Google it's free 99 you
get a five finger discount over there on
every single episode when I figure
discount that's right uh if you want if
you want to see more what was that like
you saw today go to what was
thatshow.com it'll take you directly to
Gabe Sanchez's patreon page where you
can see early episodes exclusive bits
you can see all the extras all the Q and
A's over there on patreon check it out
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez while
you're on patreon check out my page the
Tony Michaels you can see how you can
support me and all the extra content
that I do we'll probably do weekend rant
maybe some ask me anything this weekend
too
oh boy it's been a hell of a week it's
Friday we did three full hours actually
more than three hours you're welcome
you're welcome and thank you for joining
us thank you for being here because
you're the best audience in the entire
world I hope you have a great weekend
have a fun time don't do anything I
wouldn't do until Monday same time same
place Surfs Up you [__] you've
been listening to the Tony Michaels
podcast in your face commentary of
current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn head ass Beacon
foreign
[Music]
do not trust her
she is a ugly
spot
[Music]
thank you